Figma is a vector graphics editor and prototyping
tool that is great for designing websites. And
this course joy will show you how to use it. Joy
is a prolific and excellent tutorial creator. Hey
guys, you're here. This is a big material
for complete beginners. And today, you and
me together, we're going to make a complete
responsive web design, both for the desktop
version, and another one for the mobile version.
So this is the homepage of our desktop version. So
do you see this nav items over here, home teachers
contact us signing according to this nav items,
we have four pages, okay, let me walk you
through all the pages and sections. Okay,
so this is the home page, I mean, the landing
page over here, and then if I scroll down, then
we're going to find this section over here. And
then this section over here are offered courses.
This is the Education website, okay. And then if
I scroll down, then you're going to find this over
here. And then lastly, we have this footer over
here. All right, let me zoom out a little bit.
And this is the teacher section over here, you
can see that. So this is the teacher section
over here, we're going to make some cards over
here along with some buttons. And we're going to
also work with svgs. This is the footer over here
for this page. And then we have this contact us
page over here, you can see that so we're going
to also work with icons, you see these icons over
here, we're going to work with them, and also
make some forms over here as well, you can check
out the sign up page over here as well. This
is the last page, you can download this entire
figma file through the link in the description
down below. So once you download the figma file,
you're going to find all of these pages over
here. So this carries the next design. I mean,
this one over here, and this one carries the
mobile design. Look at that we have the mobile
design over here. Okay, so this is our homepage,
let me walk you through this. Okay, so this is
the homepage over here. And these are the style
guides, I'm in the typographic guides that we're
going to follow, okay, what will be the font
size of the logo, font size of the large text,
font size of the button, text, etc. Every design
carries the style guide. Okay, let me show you.
The mobile carry the style guide laptop,
the cabinet design carries the style guide
as well. The laptop design also carries this
style going over here and the next version,
this one is at the very top, we're going
to find this style guide over here.
So once you download the finger file, you're going
to find all of these pages over here you see this,
the next step carries the design for the next
version. And the mobile page carries the design
for the mobile version. Okay, so I'm going
to click over here also, you're gonna find
design for the laptop and the tablet version as
well over here. So this is a web design for the
mobile version. Okay, let me actually zoom in
a little bit like that, look at that. This is
our homepage over here. And then this is the next
section, third section, fourth section, and this
is our footer over here. Okay, let me zoom in
a little bit. There we go. And then we have our
social media icons over here as well. And
then look at this teacher section over here.
And this is the rest of the design.
So today, you and me together,
we're going to design the Dexter version. Okay,
this one, and the mobile version will see this
laptop and tablet. This is your homework. After
this tutorial, you're going to practice over here,
okay, you're going to make this web design
for the tablet version. And also you're
going to make the web design for the left version
as well. Okay, so these two are your homeworks.
This entire video is divided according to these
chapters over here, there is one over here,
you're going to find the timestamps on the
description down below. So first of all,
we're going to look at all the tools figma
carries. So once we have covered all the tools
figma carries, then we're going to start making a
responsive web design for the next version first,
and then we're going to start making the web
design for the mobile version. By the way, this
entire video is made for beginners who doesn't
know anything about figma. So we're going to start
from scratch, I will not use any plugins,
libraries or design systems just plainly from
scratch, we're going to use all the tools that
FEMA provided and we're going to make the design
using the tools only. If this video gets at least
2000 likes then I'm going to make another video at
once level figma tutorial, where I'll be covering
how to make a web design using the design system
plugins, libraries, prototypes, and also how to
save time as well. So hit the like button and
also hit the subscribe button so the gear brother
can afford them. Ah, this is Luke 800. This one.
Also note that these are our breakpoints, okay,
for the extra version, it is 1400 40 pixels, okay.
And for the laptop version, it is 1024 pixels.
And for the tablet version, this is 768 pixels.
And for the mobile version, I have picked
the 414 pixels, which is the width of the
iPhone 11 Pro max alert In this video, we'll
start according to these chapters over here.
First of all, you're going to open any
web browser, okay, and you're gonna type
figma.com fig ma.com like that, hit enter.
You're gonna find this interface over here
and then you can log in or you can sign up
don't have an account. Okay, so I have an
account. And I'm going to log in over here,
like that. I'm going to use Google over here.
So once you have signed up, you're going to
find this interface over here. Okay, let me
explain this insured. Okay, so all of these are
your draft, the projects that you're working on.
Okay, let me actually scroll down a little bit so
that I can show you some of my projects over here.
Okay, like that. And this one
over here, do you see this,
this is used to create a new draft file, I mean,
a new project. And over here on this section over
here, you're gonna find some templates over here
in order to save your time. Okay, you can scroll
down and see all of this templates over here
as well. If you want to download figma for the
next version, you can do it as well, you're gonna
click this over here, on your profile icon, okay,
like that. And then you're gonna click this get
dekstop app, and then it's going to automatically
download figma for you. Alright, now I'm going
to show you this community tab over here, okay,
I'm gonna click this, or what you can do is
you can come over here, and you can click this
community over here, and it's gonna bring you
over here. So So this community tab contains
works of other people, so that you can download
and use for your own purposes. Okay, let me scroll
down a little bit. So you're gonna find this. So
these are the trending files over here, you're
gonna find various assets over here, various
design systems, okay, so look at this over here.
These are various icons that you can download and
use for all your projects. So like that we have
tons of resources published by other people for
completely free. Alright, so I'm gonna scroll down
so that you can look more, okay. And then at the
very top over here, these, these are the filters,
okay? If you want just plugins, if you want to
just look at plugins, you can click over here,
or perhaps you want to see some illustrations,
okay, you're going to click illustrations over
here. And then you're going to find various
illustrations, various digital assets,
okay, like that. For instance, let's say
that, look at this illustration over here,
if I click over here, if you want to use this for
your project, what you're going to do is you're
going to click this duplicate option, okay,
like this. And it's going to give you a copy
to your figma file. And you can navigate the
designs, I mean, navigate the assets through
this pages over here, okay? Like the components,
look at all of these components over here. So
you got this for completely free. Okay, let me
zoom in a little bit, so that I can show you
various design assets. And if I want to change
the background color, I can also do it by this,
look at that, from purple to white like
this. Now look at my designs over here, okay?
Look at this models over here that I can use for
my projects, okay? Like this. Okay, I can zoom in,
I can zoom in and zoom out and various assets
over here, like that, look at all of this assets.
Along with the people illustrations, I
also get this over here, look at this.
In order to go back to your profile from the
community tab, what you're going to do is you're
going to click over here, okay, and then you're
going to click on your profile like this. And
you're going to come back to your figma dashboard
over here. So this is our practice project, I have
included a link in the description down below,
you click that, and you're gonna come over here.
So once you come over here, you're
gonna click this duplicate option. Okay,
so if you click on this duplicate, then it's
going to duplicate your project on your profile
like this. First of all, let's inspect what we
have on our left panel over here, you see this
panel over here. So you see this layers over here,
this layers represents all of this layers that
we have over here. And this assets over here,
I'm going to discuss in details about this one,
when I am discussing about the components
part, this one over here, part number nine.
All right, now I'm gonna come back layers over
here. And this one represents all my pages. Okay,
so these are all my pages over here, if I click
this over here, it's going to hide my pages.
If you click it back, it's going to show me all
the pages that I have. If you want to create a new
page, then you can click this plus sign over here,
and you can name it whatever you want. Like I'm
going to name page one over here, like this, and
I'm going to hit enter. If you want to delete a
page, then you can just right click over here and
delete this like that. Or perhaps if you want to
rename it, then you can click this over here. So
I'm going to delete this, okay, I don't need it.
So all our designs are arranged into these pages
over here. First of all, you have the Start button
over here, I mean start page over here, you can
see this. So you can see this thumbnail over here,
the topics covered page over here, the breakpoints
over here. And if I come to this dekstop page,
you're going to find the web design for the next
version. Okay, if I click this laptop over here,
you're going to find the design for this laptop
version. Okay, similarly for the tablet as well.
This is the design for the tablet version. This
is the mobile version. This one is the responsive
test. I'm going to discuss about this part when
I'm discussing the constraints providing this one,
Part Number eight, I have included a small sample
on this page over here so that they can test how
products work in figma. So I'm going to discuss
paradise in Part number five. And this page,
the assets page carries all our assets, all
our illustrations and social media icons,
we're going to make our web design easy, all
of this assets over here and this section,
the credit section carries all the links from
where I have downloaded the illustrations. Okay,
so you can see this over here, if you double click
over here like this, then you can copy this link,
and you can go to that link and see the
original source of the illustrations. Alright,
then I'm back to the start page over here. And
now we're here I'm going to create a new frame,
okay, by the way, all our designs are arranged in
two frames, okay, if I hit F, or if I click this
over here, this frame button, don't worry, I'm
going to discuss in details, I would all the tools
on this top panel, and on this right panel over
here, okay, if I select this frame over here,
and if I drag it like this, like that, okay,
by the way, regarding the basic movements,
you can use your mouse scroll to go top to
bottom like this, okay, if you hit Shift
and throw your mouse wheel, you can go left to
right like this. Okay, if you hit Ctrl, and if
you use a mouse scroll, then you can go zoom in
and zoom out like this, look at that. Alright.
Alright, so I'm back over here on this
frame over here, all our design in all
our elements are arranged into frames,
okay, let's say that I have a circle, okay,
I'm going to hit a ball. And I'm going to draw
a circle over here like this, that, and now I'm
going to create a rectangle, okay, if I hit r on
my keyboard, then I can draw a rectangle over here
like this. Let's say that I want some text, okay,
if I hit t on my keyboard, and click over here,
then I can write text, okay, like this. Control
a, and you increase the font size over here to 50.
Not 50, let's say 200. Okay, like that, look at
that, we have some text over here as well. And so
look over here, this is our frame, okay. And this
frame carries all our elements over here, this,
this ellipse over here, you see this ellipse,
it gets highlighted in blue, you can see this
blue highlighted color, okay? If I highlight
the rectangle, look at this, I'm selecting the
rectangle, okay, if I select the text over here,
like this, look, it gets highlighted over here.
And do you see these two buttons over here, if
I click this, then it's going to hide me the
frame like this, look at that. Okay, now look at
this, I can move this frame anywhere I want. Okay,
if I do it like this, look at that. But if
we want to lock the position of this frame,
what you can do is you're gonna click this over
here, the frame, or you can just click on the name
over here, usually, you see this frame number 52,
I'm going to click this on the name, and then I'm
going to click this lock button over here, then
it's going to lock me the position it is, it's not
going to move from its position is going to stay
fixed over here, including all the assets that is
carried on the frame. Now look, I can't select
the text, I can't select this shapes over here
as well is going to get locked over here. In order
to unlock that, I'm going to click this over here
like this unlock. Now I can move it and I can
select all of these elements over here as well
like that. So I'm going to delete this frame over
here like this. Alright, now we're going to keep
our content inside our frame as it is, or we can
also arrange them into groups, we can group them
directly, or we can also use the Auto Layout
option. So if so if I select all of them over
here, and if I right click over here, and we're
going to get this option over here, auto layout,
add auto layout, I'm going to discuss in details
about this tool on part number seven over here.
So if I right click over here, then I'm going to
get this add Auto Layout option. Along with that
I have this option group selection, if I click on
that is going to behave is going to behave like
a group. Okay, if I remove my mouse and click
over here, outside this box, then look at this,
it gets it removes the blue outline. If I click
over, if I hover over here, look, all the elements
gets highlighted, which means that it acts like
a group. Okay. So if I want to ungroup this,
what I'm going to do is I'm going to click over
here and Ctrl Shift g Ctrl, Shift g like this. Now
look, it will behave individually like that, look
at that, this is behaving individually, there is
one is behaving individually, there is one as
well. Same thing goes for the oral Layout option.
Okay, now I'm going to fill all of them again and
I'm going to create a new group over here. Okay,
group selection. Now look, it behaves like a
group. Okay, let's say that you want to move
Okay, now let's say that you just want
to select the rectangle and nothing else.
So in this cases, what you have to do is you
can double click on the rectangle like this,
there is just like just the rectangle over
here, or what you can do is you can hit Ctrl
on your keyboard control and click one time over
here, then is to select only the rectangle. If
you want just only the text, you're going to
select Ctrl on your keyboard and just select
the text over here like this, or what you have
to do is you're gonna select this whole thing,
and then double click over here like this. Look
at that, it's going to select your text over here.
Now we're going to discuss in details I want all
the tools that is listed on the top bar over here,
this one over here, and all the tools that is
listed on the right side over here. So let's
get started. Alright, The very first thing
that I want to talk about is a movement,
how will you move back and forth in
your figma file, okay, so if you hit
shift, and then if you scroll your mouse wheel,
then you can go left and right like this,
look at that. Okay, so if you release
this shift and just use your mouse scroll,
then what you can do is you can just scroll top
to the bottom like this, look at that. Okay,
so in order to go top to bottom, you're going to
use a mouse scroll like this, okay? Like that.
And if you want to go to left to right, then what
you're going to do is you're going to hit shift,
and then you're going to scroll your mouse like
that, okay, that you're going left to right,
if you want to zoom in and zoom out, what you're
gonna do is you're gonna hit Ctrl, and then you're
gonna use your mouse scroll like this, look at
that, I'm zooming out. And then I'm zooming in
like that, look at that, okay, and you can
also use this hand tool over here, okay? If you
hover over here, or perhaps you can also use
h, t on your keyboard like this. And then you
can pinch your left mouse button, or you can
just click over here, and you can just move
back and forth like this, look at that. There we
go. Let's talk about this feature over here. So
if you click over here, you have two options, the
move option and the scale option. First of all,
let's look at the move option. Okay. So if
I click this move option, or shortcut V,
okay, you can see all the shortcuts over
here v for move and scale, it is key, okay,
so I'm going to select that move option over
here, V, okay, and then I'm gonna come over here,
and then I'm going to select this frame, in order
to like this frame, you're gonna select this name
over here. And then what you're going to do is
you're gonna move it like this, look at that,
you can move freely, independently, anywhere you
want. Okay, you can select any frame you wish,
for instance, let's say that I want to select this
frame over here, okay? And then I'm gonna move it
anywhere I want like this, because that I can
move it like that, not just frame, you can move
any element, okay, if you want to move this image,
then you can also move it like this, look at that,
I have selected this and I'm going to move
it like that. I can move it anywhere I want,
like that. Okay, Ctrl zet. In order to make
you understand the scale feature, I mean,
this one even better. First of all, we need
to look at the frame feature, this one and the
rectangle feature over here. So let's go. Alright,
now I'm going to come over here and let's discuss
about the frame feature. Okay, so I'm going to
come over here and then I'm going to select this,
or shortcut, I'm going to hit F, okay, f like
this, then you're going to get all of this options
over here. Okay, who do you know what these
are, these are your, these are the screen width
of various devices. Okay, so let's say that I want
to work with mobile. Okay, so I'm gonna click this
phone over here and look at this, I have an iPhone
11 Pro max. And then you see this one over here,
this measurement, this is the width and the
height of the screen. Okay, I can also work
with iPhone eight, iPhone as a Google Pixel
two, etc. We have a lot of options over here.
But if you don't want the phone, you can also
go for the tablet, there we go. And if we want
to work with the desktop, boom, there we go. And
you can also you can even also work with watch,
like Apple watch over here. And then we have
social media post dimensions over here as
well. But if we want to make something custom,
what you are going to do is you're going to hit
F like this, and then click over here like this
and you can drag this little icon over here
anywhere you want and you can just customize the
width and height according to your needs. Okay,
so now the next thing that I want to talk about is
this one over here Okay, so what is this this is
a frame Okay, it is going to show me that it is a
frame but if you want to change it if you want to
change the frame to a custom frame, let's say that
I want to work with iPhone 11 Pro Max, okay, I'm
going to select this Now look, it's gonna change
me the width and the height like that, look at
that, but if we want to work with it, say we have
Surface Pro for okay look at this predefined width
and height Okay, if I select this, then it's gonna
give me that width and height. If I select this
now look 1368 by 912 pixels, I mean 1368 is the
width 912 is the height like that, look at that.
And also you can just drag like this according
to your needs, okay, you can adjust the width
and height, okay? So look at this x and y,
these are the coordinates I mean, where is your
frame located in your figma file, this x and y
represents that if you drag it like this with that
your frame is moving to the left, I mean to the
right, okay, if you want to move it to the left
like this, then you can also do it like that.
There we go. If you want to move it vertically,
then you can do it with the y axis over here
like that. And if you don't want that feature,
then you can just drag your frame over here and I
will click your frame over here and drag anywhere
you want. Like this, look at that. Okay, let's say
that I want to place it over Here, okay beside my
offered courses, frame over here like that, okay
that I have kept it over here, and it's gonna
give me automatic calculations over here. I didn't
have to worry about that. Now let's look at this
feature over here, the width and the height. Okay?
You can guess it by the name. This is used to set
the width and height of your frame or perhaps your
rectangles as well, or any shapes you want. Okay?
So I'm going to select this. So I'm going to
select this like this and look at this features
over here. Okay, I'm going to select this, and I
can individually set the numbers, let's say that I
want 800 pixels, Okay, I'm gonna write 800 pixels
over here, there we go. It is 800 pixels over
here. You can also do mathematical calculations
over here as well. Let's say that I want to add
another 50 pixels, Okay, I'm gonna write 50 over
here. Now I'm gonna hit enter, look at that. 850
pixels, you can also do minus multiplications,
etc, according to your needs. Okay, I'm gonna,
let's say I want to minus nine pixels
from here it is 859 pixels. So minus nine,
enter, there we go. 858 50, which is a square.
Okay, I changed my mind, I'm going to set it to,
let's say, 350 over here, like this. Look at that.
Okay, so do you know what mode this is? This is
the portrait mode over here. And let's convert it
to landscape mode. Okay, I'm gonna click this over
here like this. And do you see this tool buttons
over here? This is the portrait mode. And this
is the landscape mode. Look at this. I look at my
first of all, look at my width and height, okay,
the width is 350. Height is 650 is gonna get
shifted between these two. Okay, let me show
you. Okay, I'm going to select this over here. Now
look. So after selecting this button over here,
now look very carefully. The value of this two
jumped, it was 650. Before, and now it's 350.
Okay, it was 315 hours. 650. Now look very
carefully, I'm going to convert it back to
portrayed Okay, like this, look at that, look at
that these two values are jumping at the same time
our frame is changing over here, look
at this. There we go. Like that. If you
want to change the angle of a frame, you can
just drag over here like this, look at this,
I can change the angle of my frame. Look at
this, it is rotating. Okay, um, let me actually
zoom in a little bit. Now look at this, it will
rotate like this. Okay, we have negative values,
we have positive values. So you can just manually
do it as well like this. I'm going to set to zero
like this. There we go. Boom. Now look at this
over here. This is the corner radius. Okay? Look
here very carefully. I'm going to zoom in, you see
this, this is pointy corners, okay? So if I select
this, and if I drag like this on the right side,
now look. We can set curves on our shapes and
frames, okay? So look at this. Look very
carefully. Look at this, you see this? Okay,
now, let me talk about this one. Okay, the clip
content what this is, okay, in order to make you
understand this clip content, first of all, I'm
going to set some text over here, okay? He or you
can just select this option over here, but don't
worry, I'm going to explain in details about this
tool and all of these properties. Okay, it is
coming. Wait a minute, okay. I'm going to click
over here and then click over here like this
look, and I'm gonna select some text or it's
very big. Okay, so I'm gonna, what I'm going to do
is I'm gonna select over here, okay. 180 pixels.
I'm going to set it to 60 over here like this.
Look at that. ADF Okay. Oh, sorry. fidf. Okay,
just some random text. Okay. I just placed some
random text over here like this. Look at that.
ABC. ABC. makes more sense. Okay, so now look what
happens. Okay, I'm gonna remove that clip content
from here. Okay. Look, nothing is set over here.
Okay, now look, what I what happens is when I
resize it like this, look at this. Okay? The text
is outside, the text is outside. And the frame
is getting resized like this, look at that.
Okay, you can clearly see the content. Even if we
resize our frame, you can see that you can clearly
see the content, even if we resize our frame,
even if the frame is smaller than the content. But
look very carefully. What happens if I enable the
clip content over here like this look like?
It gets kicked like a scissor. Okay. Now if
I resize it, now you can visibly see all
the parts of our content over here. Okay,
like that. Look at that. Now, let me explain
this feature over here. You see this feature?
Resize to Fit. Now look, what
happens if I click this? Okay,
there we go. It resizes I mean, it removes all
the gaps and add just to our content. There's
one over here. This is very useful when we're
making buttons. Let me give an example. Okay,
control Zed. Let's say that I'm going to make a
button Okay, V UTP. Or like this, and I'm gonna
make it a smaller, let's say 30 pixels, okay?
And now look, and look, instead of doing this one
like this manually like this, we have
to do a lot of work over here and then
center it over here. Like this, and then
it is called a button over here like that,
instead of doing this hard work, what
you can do is control Zed, Zed, Zed, Zed,
it means I'm in going, I mean, I'm going back,
okay, by doing control Zed, like this, look at
that. So what you can do is simply, you just click
on your frame, and then you click this over here.
Resize to Fit, there we go, boom, we made
ourselves a button. This is just a sample
on how to create a button. But after a couple of
minutes, I'm going to discuss in details how to
make a button using auto layout. I mean, there's
one over here with appropriate calculations.
So wait a couple of minutes. So once that's done,
I can adjust the corners over here like this,
look at that, there we go. Like that, I can adjust
the corners, and then I can rotate it over here
like this, look at that, okay, on to exact.
And regarding the corner radius, look at this,
I have this corner, I mean, I have set it to eight
pixels, which means that it's gonna say eight
pixel over here, eight pixels here, here, here.
Let's say that I didn't want the corner radius to
be on the right side, I just want it to be on the
left side, just one single side. So what can we
do in this scenario, I'm going to select this over
here, and I'm going to click this little icon over
here, okay? And then look at this, this is called
independent corners, it is set to eight pixels for
all the four corners. Okay, so let's say that I
didn't want the corner area on the right side,
I just wanted on the left side. So what I'm going
to do is I'm going to do it like this, okay,
this is the top, this is the top left. Okay, this
is a top right, I'm going to select this and I'm
going to set it to zero like this, look at that.
Now look, the corner effect is removed. Okay,
I'm going to select this again. And I'm going to
select top left, top right, bottom left, bottom
right, this one, okay, I'm gonna select this 00
actually, sorry, my bad, I chose the wrong corner
over here, what you learn from mistakes, right?
So I'm going to select this again, and I'm gonna
say to eight pixels over here and zero over here,
like this, and then enter. Look at that. I have
corners over here on the left side, not on the
right side. There we go. Now let's discuss about
this feature, get the slice feature. So what
this is used is, let me actually come to my,
let me actually delete this, okay? I'm going
to come on to this frame over here, okay,
let's say that I just want not the whole image, I
just want the head, okay, I just want to download
the head, I just want to work with the head. Okay,
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to click this
over here, slice, okay? And then I'm gonna draw a
rectangle over here on the head section, can you
see this properly? Okay, there we go. Now look, I
have a little slice over here, you can see this,
okay? Now what I'm going to do is I'm going to
select this slice over here, either from here,
or I can directly select it here, okay, and then I
can adjust the width and height as well like this,
look at that. Alright, and I can also move it
like this, look at that, there we go. And then
I'm going to click it over here. And then can
you see this Export button over here, I'm gonna
click this export, who is downloading this, okay,
I'm gonna click this plus sign over here. And you
can set the image quality as well, you can set it
to PNG, jpg, SVG, I'm gonna do it in SVG. Okay,
I'm gonna select this, and then I'm going to
export this one, look at this, I have downloaded
a little file over here. So what I'm going to
do is I'm going to drag it over here like this,
look at this, I just look at this over here, I
just downloaded I mean, I just sliced the head,
because I just only need to work with the height
head. Okay, now look, look at this. This is equal
to this one over here, this slice over here,
I hope you understood the slice properly.
Now, regarding this Export button, you
can download anything you want. Okay,
let me actually give you a demo. Okay, I'm going
to delete this home here. And at the same time,
I'm going to remove this slice from here
as well. And let's say that I want to
download this single frame over here, okay, just
single frame, or perhaps even just the drying,
we're here I'm in the illustration, I just want
to download the illustration and nothing else.
Or you can also download multiple files as well
like tricky by clicking this one and then shift,
then click like this, then click like this as
well. Now, let's say for keeping this simple,
I'm going to download this image, okay, I'm
going to click this over here, and then I'm
going to scroll down at the button over here.
And then look at this, I have the Export button,
I'm gonna click over here and then look at
this. You can change the size as well you can
download it two times three times or four times
the actual size, okay? And then we have the PNG,
SVG, jpg, PDF, etc formats, okay, you can download
anywhere you want, I mean, you can download,
you can download in any format you want and
then you're gonna hit this export frame button.
And yeah, this feature this preview option
is given just to let you know that what you
are downloading Okay, you can see this I
have just selected this frame, I mean, this
illustration over here, let's say that I
want to see like this text over here, okay,
I'm gonna select this text and I'm going to
select this export like this. And look at that.
It is giving it is giving me this preview that
I have just downloaded in there. text over here.
Now let's discuss the shape feature. Okay, so
I'm going to come over here, you see this shape,
it looks like a square, Okay, I'm gonna select
this like this, look at this, I have a lot of
options. I have rectangle, line, arrow, ellipse,
polygon, etc. Let's say that I want a polygon,
sorry, I want an ellipse, okay, I'm
going to click this, or I can select Oh,
so I'm going to select all like this and look at
this, I can make a circle over here. But look,
this circle looks distorted. And it's going to be
very hard for me to make a perfect circle. So in
this case, what I'm going to do is I'm going to
select, I mean, I'm going to hit shift. Now look,
it instantly became a perfect circle. And now
while holding Shift, I can just move my mouse
and look, it's gonna give me a perfect circle like
this. Look at that. Okay, this is a perfect circle
over here, I'm gonna delete this. And I have more
options like a rectangle, okay? And I'm gonna
select rectangle like this, look at that. Okay, I
can do it anywhere I want. I can move it anywhere
I want. And I can select the width and height
accordingly. Okay, look at this. I'm moving
this and I'm resizing this like this. And do you
see this little dot over here, this dot this dot,
dot dot over here, it is used to set the radius,
look at this corner radius, you can do it over
here, or you can, you can do it over here directly
like this. Or what you can do is you can select
this options over here, okay, like this, as I told
you a little bit earlier, okay, you can do it like
this as well. And yeah, do you remember the scale
button? I'm do remember this Scale tool over here.
This one, as I told you that I'm going to discuss
in details after discussing this frame and this
rectangle. Now I'm going to discuss this. Okay, so
what were the scale button is used, let's say that
you want to scale I mean, you want something,
let's say that you want to make something bigger.
Okay? So in the case of this circle, do you
remember this circle this distorted circle, okay,
with this, you cannot make it a perfect circle.
Let's say that I have selected a shift. Okay,
shift. Now look, it looks like a perfect circle.
Okay, I have released the chip, then let's say
that you want to make it a little bigger. Okay,
what you normally do is, you're going to select
this like this, look at this, okay, when you
try to make it bigger, it is going to get
distorted again. So in this case, what you can do
is you can just simply select the shift, and it's
going to resize accordingly. Or what you can do
is you can select this scale function over here,
you can select this over here directly or you can
just select the K option on your keyboard, okay,
okay. And look at this, I have a different icon on
my mouse, okay, I'm going to select V, which means
move, okay, look at this icon on my mouse. Okay,
I'm gonna zoom in a little bit over this. This is
V, this is for the move, this is the default. And
if I want to resize this K, look at this scale,
and this is move. Okay, I'm gonna give K over
here like this. Now I'm gonna resize Look,
it's gonna resize proportionately, and
proportional measurements, okay, now look at this,
okay? 788 by 788. Okay, I'm gonna resize it
again. Now look at that, it's gonna give me
accurate proportion measurements. So I'm gonna
remove this circle from here and I'm going to draw
a perfect square, okay, shift, and then, oh,
sorry, I'm gonna hit R, which means rectangle,
or you can just select it from here as well,
and shift and then drag like this. Look at this.
This is a perfect square. Okay, now let's talk
about this feature this field feature Okay,
this is used to color your rectangle, I mean,
color your shapes like this. To do that,
you can color it anything you wish. You can also
put input the hex value, you can also change
the opacity over here, you can also use this
predefined colors. Let's say that I want to use
sky blue over here because that enable also uses
dropper tool. Okay, if you select this dropper
tool, then you can select anything you wish. Let's
say that I want my box I'm in my square to be
the color of this. Okay, so I have this eyedropper
on my hand. And when I select this over here,
like this, now look at my square over here, look,
this is the same color as this one over here.
Now let's look at more features that we have no
right panel over here. Okay, this features Okay,
I'm going to select it over here and I'm
going to change it to the default color. Okay,
wait a minute, e4, e4 info like this. Oh, sorry.
There we go. It is c four c four, c four. Alright,
so the first thing that I want to discuss is the
stroke. So what this does is it gives a stroke
around our box. Okay, let me show you Okay, okay,
I'm gonna select this like this. We're gonna,
it's gonna generate me a little stroke over
here. Okay, can you see this black colored
outline over here? I'm gonna increase its width
okay like this look 345678 910 so the stroke is
10 pixels. Okay, can you see this black color tick
stroke over here. You can also change the various
properties like the color the size, then should it
be inside the box. Should it be on the center or
should it be outside the box like that, look at
that, you can also hide the shadow, I mean, you
can also hide the stroke like this. If you select
this eye button over here like that, look at that.
You can also click it over here again, and it's
going to show me the stroke over here. And if
you want to remove this stroke permanently,
you can also use the minus button over here
like this, look at that, it went away. Okay,
now we're gonna look at this FX feature. Okay,
for that, I'm gonna just resize this a little
bit like that. Okay, now, if I select this
effect button, look at this, I have this panel
over here, okay, I have a lot of options. Like
if I want to make a drop shadow, or if I want
some layer blur, or perhaps background blur,
we have Inner Shadow as well. For now I'm
going to show you the drop shadow. Okay,
I'm going to select this over here. And yes, you
can experiment on your own. And look at this,
I have a little bit of shadow, you see this
shadow at the back of this rectangle? Let me
actually remove that child. Okay, look at this.
You see that? Do you see the shadow over there?
Okay, I am hiding the shadow. Now let me bring
that shadow back. Look at this. So this so
this drop shadow is used to make shadows, draw
shapes, frames, buttons, cards, etc. Alright,
so now look at this over here. This is called
the effect setting. Okay, so I'm going to click
over here and then I can adjust the shadow.
Okay, so this is the x, which means that my
shadow will move left and right like
this, look at that. Okay, look at this,
look, my shadow is moving left and right, if I
want to, if I want to move the shadow, top to
the bottom, like this, I'm going to use this wide
button over here. Okay, like that. Look at that.
And then if I want the shadow to spread, I'm
going to use the spread over here like that, look,
look, the shadow is getting bigger, okay, and
smaller as well. And you can also change the
color over here, opacity over here as well.
And if you want to change the blur, you can
do it like this. There we go. We're increasing the
blur. So we're going to include this drop shadow
when we are making buttons. Okay, let me actually
give you a demo. Look at this, our buttons have a
little bit of drop shadow over here, as well as
this cards, look at these cards. Okay, this has
drop shadow. So when we're making this layout, I
mean, when we're doing this design, we're going
to utilize this drop shadow. Whatever I have
discussed so far, this is the design section,
okay, on the right panel. So this is a prototype
over here. After a couple of minutes, I'm going
to discuss about this for a live Okay, so don't
worry, and look at this inspect over here. Okay,
so if I go to inspect, then is gonna generate
me CSS code. Let's say that I want the code of
this one. Okay, this section over here, then I'm
going to select this over here and look at this.
It is generating the CSS over here like this, look
at that. If you're a developer, you can save time.
Look at this display, flex flex direction, column
justify content center, align items, flicks start,
so on and so forth, along with all of this
look, pixel measurements over here along with
the padding with height, etc. So this inspect tool
is very handy. Alright, now I'm going to discuss
in details about all of these tools over here.
These are the alignment tools. Okay? So in order
to discuss about that, I'm going to come over
here and I'm going to draw a frame, okay, F and
then I'm going to drag it like this, look at that.
Okay, so now I'm gonna write some text, okay, D,
and then click over here, and then some text over
here, okay, like that. Okay, let me actually write
ABCD. Okay, ABCD like that on through a capital
letter A, A, A, B, C, D, there we go. Let's say
that I want this text to be at the very center.
So what will we do? Okay, so if we come over here,
look at this Align Horizontal center, if I click
over here, like this, now look, our text is at the
very center, horizontally, okay? If I wanted
to be at the very center vertically, I mean,
if I wanted to be at the very center over here,
so what I'm gonna do, what am I gonna click, I'm
gonna click over here, look at this. This is the
Align Vertical Centers like this, look at that,
it is at the very center, both horizontally and
vertically. Let's say that I want to move it to
the very left at the very left, okay, what I'm
going to do is I'm going to click this over here,
like this. This is alignment left. If you want
alignment, right, you can also do it like this,
this option over here like this. So you can
experiment with all of these values over here.
And regarding this, I'm going to delete
this over here like this real quick. And
regarding this panel over here, I'm in this
tool over here. And regarding this text,
this is the file name, okay, if you
double click over here, then you can
rename it Okay, so I'm going to keep it figma
file over here, I'm in figma tutorial over here
like that as it is and if you click over here
like this, you can download this figma file,
you can also duplicate it, you can rename it
any goal to delete this as well. So these are
the options that you have. You can also share it
with their friends that what you created so far,
like you created this frames over here if you
want to share it with their friends or perhaps
if you want to share it with your clients, then
you can click the Share option over here and then
you're going to find appropriate details. Okay,
so I'm gonna remove this night right now and Okay,
now regarding this button over here, this is
called a present button. So if you click on here,
then you can see your designs life at the
same time. If you're working with prototype,
then you can also view your I mean, you can also
test the interactivity of your prototypes live.
Don't worry, I'm going to discuss this product
after a couple of minutes. Okay? So let's say that
I'm going to click on here, okay, after selecting
this design over here, okay, I'm gonna click this,
I can feel this over here. Now look at this, this
is the desktop type program. Okay? And if I come
over here, if I click this arrow over here, then
it is going to go next like this. Wait a minute,
these are the sections. Look at this. This is my
design over here. Okay, I can view it over here.
No, no, this is very large. Okay, I want to
make it small. So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to come to this options, and then I'm gonna,
I'm gonna select this fit, scaled down to fit,
okay, like this. There we go. Now, now it looks
much better. Okay, so I'm gonna come over here,
and I'm gonna go next. Or perhaps you can also
use an arrow right like this, look at that,
he's gonna move to the next frame like this.
So by this way, you can preview your designs,
what you create so far, okay, you can view
it like this. Look at that. There we go.
Now we're going to discuss that what the text tool
in details. So this tool over here, the text tool
is used to add text to all Web Designs. So if you
notice carefully that every design the desktop,
tablet, laptop, mobile contains this chart over
here, okay, this is the typography guide chart
shows that what should be the font size of
the logo, the font size of the nav items,
font size of the large text, font size of
the small text, the text of the button, etc,
along with the line height over here. So you can
see that the line height of large should be 90 and
line height of small should be 43. Over here. Same
goes for the mobile design as well look at this
over here, I have included the mobile typographic
over here, the logo, this logo is 48 pixels,
then large text 32 button is 24 pixels, so
on and so forth. It also this chart is also
mentioned for the laptop as well. So look at
this over here, this is the laptop design over
here. And this one is the typography for the
laptop design. Okay, so the logo is 60 pixels,
the button should be 30 pixels, so on and so
forth. So I'm going to come over here, and
over here, I'm going to create either a rectangle
or a frame, so you can so we can hit our like
this, and it's going to create me a rectangle,
what I'm going to use a frame over here, okay,
control that. So if if you hit F like this, it's
going to create a frame like this, look at that.
Okay, I'm going to make the frame a little
smaller, let's say 1000 by 500. Okay, that will do
for this tutorial like this, look at that.
Alright, then in order to use the text tool,
you directly click over here like this, and it's
going to highlight blue over here and you're
going to get a plus sign on your mouse, can you
see my mouse over here it is in plus sign, okay.
And if you want to do it in a shortcut way, you
just hit t on your keyboard like this T and it is
going to highlight that text over here on your
mouse. And if you click anywhere, then you can
get this sign over here you see this then
you can add text like this, look at that
it is said 210 pixels, but by default, your text
should be 12 pixels like this, which means that
Wait a minute, it should be on curved pixels
like this, which means that it's going to be
very small. So what you're going to do, you're
going to click over here okay. And you see this
option over here this is used to set the font size
so what is the font size of all dekstop let's say
it is for the logo is 90 pixels, okay? So
let's say to nine pixels, like this look,
it is set to 12 I'm gonna set 90 over here like
this, okay, pay that enter and then is the output
mean this result Okay, so this is used to set the
font size. And this one you see this this is used
to set the font family, it is kinda set to Roboto
and if I click over here and I can change the font
family as well like this, it should be let's say
we're going to say to Poppins like this p o p p i
ns Poppins, okay, now look, the font family
changes. Similarly, I can also write sans serif
over here, sans. Let's go for sensation. Okay,
I'm going to hit enter like this. Look at that it
changed. And if you click this drop down icon over
here like this, then you have tons of options of
for fonts. You can pick any font family you
want, like this, look at that. So I'm going
to say to pop in like this p o p p i ns Poppins
like that, and I'm going to name over here, a
do.io like this, okay, because we're going to
deal with this logo after all. Okay, so now the
next thing that I'm going to show you is this one,
okay? This is the font weight, it is kind of set
to red, it is currently set to regular. You can
also set extra light over here like this. Look at
that. The font weight changes, okay? You can also
say To set it to paint like this, look at that it
became thin. You can also say to this extra ball,
look at that how bold this text is. Okay, I hope
you understood it so far. And you see this over
here. So this is used to set the line height, look
at that it is written highlighted over there line
height, okay, so I'm going to insert it to let's
say regular, okay, like this. So um, this logo
should be regular. And in order text in, I'm in
a retest this line height, you cannot just simply
test with just a single line, you need multiple
lines, okay, so I'm going to delete it over here
like this, and I'm going to drag this one, just
text, you see this text over here, I'm going to
drag it to our test case. So in order to drag it,
so what you're going to do is you're gonna control
you're going to hit control, okay, and then just
pick this text over here like this. And then I'm
going to zoom out, and I'm going to click the old,
I'm gonna select the alt text like this old, and
you see my mouse is getting a little shadow on
its back, like two months together. Okay, so I'm
gonna select the old text and I'm going to move my
mouse like this, look at that, it is getting
copied, Okay, I'm gonna come over here and
don't move. Okay, just First of all, just release
your mouse click like this, okay, and then you're
going to release the Alt key like this look. Now
we have successfully copied our text on here,
okay? Now look at this. Now, now we're gonna
come over here, and we're gonna see like this,
like this, and then we're gonna see this,
okay? Look at here, line height is set to 43.
And if we want to change it, then you're gonna
click over here, or you can directly you can
directly put the number over here like this, let's
say I want to say 210 pixels like this, okay? If I
click enter, now, look, it has 112 110 pixels of
gap over here. Let's say that I want to set it to
20. Okay, you can directly input it over
here, like this 20 Look at that, it became
very congested like this. Okay, so if you click
over here, you see this, I got a small icon, okay,
arrow sign icon like this, I'm going to move my
mouse like this. Now, look, I can practice with
this real time like this without worrying about,
I mean, without directly inputting the value over
there. Okay, look at that I'm just playing out,
I'm just playing around with a mouse so that I
can find that sweet spot, which would be ideal,
which will be the ideal line height. Okay, so I'm
going to change it to 43. Like that, because it is
actually given on the style guide over here. Wait
a minute, over here, look at that the small text,
it should be 30 pixels. And look at this, the line
height should be 43 pixels, okay? I'm going to
come over here like this. And look at this, the,
the font size is 30 over here, and it is set to
Poppins and the line height is 43. Over here. Now,
do you see this over here, this is called a ledger
spacing. So line height works like this, okay,
but the letter spacing, legislating works like
this is going to put cap between our little
like this, okay, I'm going to show you Okay, I'm
going to keep it over here like this. And watch
very carefully. Oh, by the way, you can
also input direct value over here like this,
clearly over here like this, then it's going
to be 30%. Or perhaps you can also set this,
I mean, you can also use this mouse over here,
and you're going to get this little arrow sign,
okay? So I'm going to drag like this look at
that is going to change according to my mouse
movement. Okay, look at that, like this, it's
working like that. So this is used to set the
ledger spacing, I hope you understood it so
far. I'm gonna set it to zero over here like
this. Now look at this one. This is called the
paragraph spacing, okay, in case if you have
multiple paragraphs, then this is going to work.
Okay. So if I drag like this over here, then you
can see this behavior, it is working like a line
height, but it should not work like a line height.
Because I have actually used some gap over here
like this, it may actually show you wait a minute,
I'm going to set it to default controls that
control set again like that, okay. So what
is happening is I have given some line break over
here and there so it is behaving like a parallel,
but if I set it to it, or you know, state like
this, wait a minute, just give me a second,
okay? It is actually the ordinal state.
Look at this long text over here. Okay. Now,
I'm going to shrink it like this. Look at this.
Okay, I'm going to shrink it like this. And it's
going to behave like this. Okay, let me actually
zoom in. There we go. I hope you can see this.
I hope you can see my screen. Okay. I'm going to
look at this. This is behaving just like a single
paragraph. Okay, now look, now look what happens
if I use it. Okay. Now, look, it is not working.
The paragraph spacing is not working. This will
only work when you have multiple paragraphs. Okay,
let me actually show you okay. I'm going to copy
this one over here like this. Let's say two lines,
okay. Ctrl C, and then I'm going to paste
it over here like this. Ctrl V, there we go.
So how many parents do we have? We have two
parents. Now look at this paragraph height.
I mean, paragraph spacing, we said 23 pixels. I'm
going to drag my mouse like this. Look at that.
I can see range that paragraph spacing but look,
it's it's it is set to zero but there is some gap
over here that is the gap of your line height.
Look at that. Okay, you can also right over here,
but if you remove that whitespace from here,
then look, is it gonna work like that? Now look,
it is set to zero, exact zoo. Okay, I'm
gonna drag it over here like this. Now look,
it is working perfectly fine. There we go. Let's
do the next feature. Okay, I'm going to click over
here and look at this. Do you see this? This is
the text align left text align center text align,
right. Okay, let's experiment. Okay, so I'm going
to drag it, I'm going to drag the window like
this, okay, over here like this. Look at that.
Now look, the text is behaving on the left side,
okay, text align left. Now I'm gonna change the
center. Okay, you see this third line over here,
look at that it is set to left. Now he's gonna
move to the middle like this, okay, if I click
over here, like this text, align center. Now look,
it is changing the alignment, the text alignment
is changing to center like this. And I have also
the option of right over here, look at that,
right text align, right. So if we want to, if we
want the option of justify, you're going to click
this little icon over here, okay, wait a minute,
we're gonna click this little icon over here.
And then you're going to find this justify over
here, which means that is gonna, appropriately,
I may equally distribute the spaces in a way
that it fills the whole box over here. Okay,
so let me actually make this para into a line like
this. Now look at that, you see this one, this
line over here, and this line over here, look,
the text are equally distributed inside the box so
that it looks like text align justified. Alright,
so I hope you understood this alignment tools over
here. Now look at this tool over here, okay, or
a width, or a height, and then fixed size. So,
so in order to discuss this tools over here, first
of all, what you're going to do is you're gonna
reduce the size of your font size, okay? So
I'm going to set it to let's say, let's say
2020 pixels like this. Okay, now, let's
say I want to drag it like this, okay,
I'm going to drag that box like that. Now, look,
this is behaving like a fixed height, which means
that our pair over here will occupy What is this
912 pixels of weight into 286 pixels of height. So
it is going to occupy that much amount of space in
on our web design or perhaps on our on our frame.
Okay, so I can drag it like this. Now, look, it
is gonna, I mean, those snapping guides. Okay,
you see, this orange Schiller's colored guide
over here is going to work according to our box,
I mean, the box which carries the text, okay, so
this is how the fixed height, I mean, fixed size
works, but if you snap it to or a width, which
means that it's gonna hug the content inside the
box, so that there is no additional spaces, look
at this, you see this box over here, along with
the blue colored guides, okay, so I'm gonna click
over here, which is or a width, now look at that,
it is going to work as if it is a single line,
first of all, and the next thing is, is not
going to keep any additional gaps. Okay, so let's
say that, I want to break the line, okay, I want
to break the line over here like this. So you can
also do it, you can also break the line like that,
there we go, it's gonna work like that. And if I,
let's say, for any instance, this changes to like
this, okay, it's gonna, let's say that it changed
to this. So what you're gonna do is if you want to
reduce those white spaces, normally, most of
the people, what they do is they're gonna do it
like this look. They're gonna do it like this. But
this will not give you exact measurements. I mean,
it is not the ideal scenario. So what you're
going to use is you're going to use this little
icon over here with auto auto Wait, okay, the
auto hide, wait a minute, these auto hide works
in a similar manner, okay, it just works with the
height. Okay, I'm gonna click over here. And if
I select this, then it's gonna automatically
snap those height and remove those whitespace
from my text like that. Okay, now let's look at
this tools over here, these three tools over here,
okay, this is align top, align, and the middle
and align and the bottom. Okay, let's say that
I have this text and I'm going to resize it like
this. Okay, now look, I have a lot of space inside
my rectangle. And where does my text where's my
text aligned, it is aligned at the top, very top.
If I want to take it on the middle like this,
okay, I can use this one over here like this,
look at that, it's gonna come to the middle inside
this box. And let's say that I want to take my
text at the very center. Okay, what I'm going
to use is I'm going to use this little icon over
here, Li important. I get like that, look at that.
It has aligned, it has aligned to the model. So
let's change it back like this at the top and then
or a week like this. There we go. Now let's look
at this tools over here. Okay, you see these three
dots. So we're here, if you select this like this,
then you're going to have more tools. Okay, first
of all, you're going to get this alignment tools
over here, and then the decorations. Okay? So
if you hover over here, then you're going to get
live preview what each every tool does, like this,
look at this underline tool is going to underline
my text, okay? If I select this like this, you're
going to not only see the result over here, live,
look at that, look at this little screen, okay,
you can also see the result over here, okay,
like that. So I'm going to click it over here
as well. So if I want to remove the declaration,
then I'm going to select this over here like
this, none, then you can also strike through
the text like this, you have a lot of options.
If you want to make two lists, look at this list
option over here, okay, if I click this, then it's
going to create me a list, okay? unordered list.
And if we want to make it an ordered list, then
you can click this over here, an ordered list
in 123, so on and so forth. So if we want
paragraph indentation, you're going to utilize
this feature. Okay, wait a minute, this paragraph
indentation feature, okay. So if you say it,
let's say 30 pixels like this, okay? Oh, this
is actually not working. That's because we
have multiple line breaks. So I'm gonna make it
just a single line, like this. Wait a minute,
just give me a second and then I'm gonna drag this
inside my frame. Okay. Wait a second like that.
There we go. And it is just working like a single
paragraph and then oral height like this. I mean,
oral width like this. Okay. Oh, I did in
the wrong way. My bad. Sorry. Okay, now,
looks good. Now, look, I have some paragraph
indentation at the very first of the text. Okay,
look at this. We have 30 because we have 30 pixels
of gap over here. If we want to increase the gap,
let's say 100. Let's go 400. Okay, 100 like this.
There we go. We have 100 pesos of gap over here.
Let's look at more options that we have. Okay, so
we have the lowercase over here. Okay, this is the
default, I mean, the way you write it is going to
be default. Okay. So if we want all the text to
be capital sized, okay, you have this uppercase,
okay? Now look at this text, okay? lorem ipsum
dolor state, okay, it is in small text, lowercase
letter, okay, I'm going to change it to uppercase
letter. Okay, I'm going to click over
here and then I'm going to click this,
okay? It is the preview, it is going to
give me a preview over here as well. Okay,
so I'm going to click this over here. Now look,
all the text all later has changed to upper
upper case letters, okay, like this, look
at that. You can also change it to lowercase
letters, I by clicking this, again, look
at that all the texts are I mean, all the
letters are lowercase. By the way, if you want to
change the color of your text, what you have to do
is you're going to select any text, okay, let's
say that I want to see like this text over here,
okay, so I'm going to what I'm going to do is I'm
going to Ctrl and then click over here like this,
okay? Or what you can do is you can double click
over here like this, and it is going to get
selected, okay, okay. And then what you're going
to do is you're gonna scroll down over here,
and you see this fill option over here, you
can change the color over here by inputting
your hex value over here, or what you can do is
you can just select this option over here, okay,
you can get this eyedropper over here, which
means that you can pick any color you want,
like this look, I'm going to select this over
here like this. Let's say that I want to change
it to this color over here. Okay, so I'm going to
select this ello the text gets colored according
to this color over here. Similarly, what you
can do is you can drag this little small dot
over here and you can play any way you want and
the color changes accordingly. Okay, I'm gonna
move this ball over here, and you're gonna
see the changes over here. Okay, look at this,
I'm going to change the black letter sound, I want
to, I want to change it to black, let's say like
this, okay, and let's say I want to change it to
white. Okay, I'm gonna go over here like this.
By the way, you can also move this over here to
change the color. Okay, let's say I want to go to
red. Okay, I'm going to come to red over here, and
this palette over here turns to red, okay, and I
can move it over here as well like this. Okay?
If you want to change the opacity, then you can
change it over here like this look, I'm gonna
look I'm gonna drag this slider over here and
look at this effect over here. Okay, it's gonna
get changed. Okay, look at this. I'm going to drag
it and look, the opacity changes, okay, if
I turn it to zero, it's gonna be invisible.
Okay, effort. If we go to absolute zero, like
this, then is going to get invisible. Okay,
so ladies and gentlemen, we're done discussing
the text tool along with all its properties.
As a beginner, you don't have to understand
prototypes. So this is a feature that I'm
discussing right now, the paradigm over here,
this one okay, but for the sake of this tutorial,
and to make you understand how and where the
product feature is used, I have created a
small section over here on this page, okay, so
you can see this for right sample, you're gonna
come over here okay. Now you can see two designs
over here, okay, this is the mobile design. Now,
let me tell you where product is used. prototype
is used to make interactive web designs. So I have
kept an example over here on this section. Okay.
Perfect. sample. So now what I'm going to do is
I'm going to click over here, okay? For right like
this. Now look, I already created some frames over
here, but I'm going to delete it. Okay? So
I'm going to click it over here like this.
And I'm going to delete, and then I'm going
to click over here and then delete. Okay,
so I'm starting, I'm starting from
scratch in order to make, sorry.
So I'm starting from scratch, in order to make
you understand how the system works. I mean,
the product how prototype works. So first of
all, let's understand this model over here. Okay,
so this is our nav bar over here. And this is
the hamburger menu icon over here. Okay, so the
moment we click this menu icon over here, okay, is
gonna get converted to this cross sign over here,
and then this content over here will get vanished.
And then it's going to show us our menu items over
here, like home teacher, so on and so forth, etc.
In order to create a portrait, right, what you're
going to do is you're going to click over here,
okay, this section for right like that, and you're
going to get this instructions over here. Okay,
so the first thing that we're going to do is,
I'm going to select this, okay, by double
clicking over here, like that, look at that,
I have selected this hamburger menu icon. Okay, so
look at this, do you see this plus sign over here?
It means that the moment we click on here, or the
moment we tap on here, where do we where will this
lead us to? Okay? It's going to lead us to this
frame over here. I mean, this design over here,
okay, so I'm gonna click and drag this one like
this, look at this arrow on my hand. Okay, I'm
going to drag it like this over here. There we go.
So this is getting linked to this one over here.
All right, and then it's going to give me this
option over here. So look at this interaction
details that popped up. Okay, so it's telling
me it's asking me how this interaction should
take place. Okay, should it be on click or on
drag, all while hovering while pressing, then
we have mouse and we have a lot of options over
here to pick from what what For this tutorial,
I'm going to keep it very simple, okay? On click,
which means that the moment we click this one
over here, then it is going to choose this frame
over here, okay. And then we also need to click
over here, so that we can go back to this main
content over here. So how do we do this, we're
going to do the same thing. Okay, we're going
to double click over here on this cross site.
And then you see this little plus over here, let
me zoom in, you see this little plus over here,
we're going to select that and drag it back to
this main frame over here like this. Okay, that,
there we go. And there is also going to show
me this interaction designs, I'm interaction
details. Okay, so what I'm going to do is, I'm
going to keep it as it is, and then look at this
animation over here. So I'm going to click over
here. So instead of instead, I'm going to select
dissolve over here like that. So you have a bunch
of, I mean, a lot of options to choose from,
but I'm going to keep it very simple, just
dissolve, okay, like that. And I'm going to select
this one as well. And I'm gonna set the animation
to dissolve as well like that, look at that. Now
look, in order to test this prototype, what
you have to do is you're going to click this
play button over here, do you see this play
button over here. And when I click it like this,
now let's experiment, it's going to create a new
window over here, okay? And there we go. Look
at this, our design is over here. I mean, this is
our prototype over here, okay? Now, look at this,
look at my mouse over here, wherever, wherever I
go, it is just a mouse, okay, but wherever, what
whenever I come over here, look at this is gonna
turn into a pointer, which means that this is
clickable. If I click over here, then it's going
to give me some animations or interactions. Okay,
now look, I'm gonna test it over here like this.
Okay, I'm gonna click like this, look at that.
Look at that, we have our navigation menu
items over here. And we also have this cost
center over here. Okay, I'm going to click
over here again, like that, we're gonna,
it went back to our frame, main frame
over here. Let's experiment again. Okay,
click like this. There we go. And then in order
to go back to that, you see this animation,
this dissolve animation, look at that. It is
just fading in fading out. I really hope that
you understood the product feature. If you want to
experiment with the product, you're going to come
to this section over here the prototype sample
and follow the instructions that I have given you.
Now we're going to discuss that with
a feature called auto layout. Today,
I'm going to show you two use cases how to use the
auto layout. First of all, I'm going to show you
how to align your content, this content over here,
this text this text this button at the same time,
I'm going to show you how to make this button
over here using the auto layout. So now you're
going to come over here like this, and we're
going to create a new frame over here, okay,
so you hit F like this on your keyboard, okay,
and then you're going to drag it like this. Look
at that. We have created ourselves a new frame.
Okay, let me actually resize it a little bit.
Like this. Look at that. Okay, it looks
quite good. And then now I'm going to create
a text Okay, so d and then I'm going to
place it over here like this, okay, I'm
going to write something like this. And then I'm
gonna set the size to let's say 60 pixels. Okay,
wait a minute. It's gonna work like now 16. There
we go. And now I'm going to duplicate this. Okay,
let's say that I want to duplicate this
to James, okay, I'm going to select the
keyboard named alt, okay? And then I'm
going to drag it like this, look at that,
okay, it's gonna get copied, okay? Alt, and
then use your mouse like this, look at that out,
and then mouse is gonna duplicate me the same
thing. Okay, control Zed. Now, where is the oral
layout used? Let's say that this text are over
here like this, look at that, okay, in this array,
let's say that I want to align them to the very
left, or exact measurements, how what I mean,
look at this over here, you see this text, one,
two, and then this button over here, you see,
all of these elements are aligned to this box,
this blue colored box over here on the very left
on exact accurate measurements. So if we
want to copy this layout over here like this,
then what we generally have to do is we have
to individually select this element, okay? And
then we have to take the help of this guy's over
here, do you see this orange color guide that is
showing me the number of gaps 57 pixels, okay?
If I come over here, like this, look at this,
the orange color guide is getting highlighted.
Okay, let me show you again. Okay, look at this,
okay, now look, this is on accurate, left, Align
Left, okay. And then if I drag it over here,
like this, now look, it's gonna get aligned
to the left, according to this size over here,
okay. And then let's say that I want to decrease
the size over here, okay, I'm going to select
this like this, okay, I'm going to do it like
this, and it got decreased reduced in size.
And let's say that I want to decrease it even
further. Okay, I'm going to remove these letters
from here like this. Okay, now, let's say that I
want to change the gap in between this content,
okay, it's gonna be a hassle, okay, you have to
just individually take your mouse, and then you
have to place it like this. And if you want
to calculate the space, what you have to do
is you're gonna click any element, let's say that
I want to click this element, okay, this element,
and then I'm gonna select my Alt key on my
keyboard like this. And then wherever I place,
my mouse is going to show me that calculation.
Like look at this, the distance between these
two elements, okay, is 51 pixels, look at this
orange color guide, it is highlighting 51 pixels.
Similarly, let's say that I want to select this
and calculate the gap between these two content,
okay, I'm going to select out, and then I'm going
to put a mouse on this content, look at this
39 pixels. This is how it works. But it's
gonna be a long hassle if you do it manually.
So in this case, what you can use is the auto
layout. Okay, let me actually show you okay.
I'm going to click all of them together, and then
I'm going to right click like this and look at
this option or add auto layout. Okay, I can do it
over here like this, or do you see this option?
shortcut keys shift a, you can also press the
shift n is going to work, okay? Like this,
look at that. Okay, now look, if I.
So if you notice on the right side,
you see this new section over
here, this is called oral now,
okay, if you want to remove the oral layout,
then you're going to select this minus over here,
okay? And then it's going to remove it and convert
it back to a frame. How do you know when it gets
converted to a frame? Okay, you're gonna actually
you're gonna show you're gonna see on the right
side, okay, look at this, okay, this hashtag,
this hashtag means the frame. Now, if you go
back by selecting control Zed like this, look
at this over here, wait a minute, look at this,
we have two rows like this, I mean, two lines
like this, this represents the auto layout. Okay,
now let's look at the options that we have.
Okay, so I'm going to select this like this,
and it's going to highlight me that auto layout,
okay, look at this, I have 45 pixels of gap in
between each of this content, okay? So if I
drag my mouse like this limit, the amount of
gap in between this content changes, okay, like
this, look at that, again, lowest is zero, and
upper limit is anything you wish, okay, like this,
let's say I want to set it to 25 pixels like this,
look at that. And this one, look at this one, this
is used to add padding around your continuity,
let me show you Okay, I'm going to select this
and drag it like this, we're gonna look at this
padding is getting added all around my content
like this, look at that, if we want to change
again, like this, look, padding is getting applied
like that. Now let's talk about this feature over
here. padding and alignment. Okay. So if I, let's
say that I want to increase my size of my content,
okay, like this, look at this. I'm gonna drag
my blue colored box like this and it is gonna
increase in size. Let's say that I want to place
a condom at the very center. How do I do this,
in order to do it quickly, easily efficiently,
we're going to use this tool alignment and
panning, okay, and when I select like this, and
look at this, I have so many options. I can select
it any I can place it anywhere I want. So our
criteria is where to set it at the very center.
How do we do it? We're gonna click this over here,
you see this over here, option. Look at that.
It got centered on our box over here. Okay,
so let's say that I want to see like this,
I want to place it on this corner over here
on this corner over here, we can do it.
So you're gonna see like this, like
this, look at that. It's gonna get
Move to this section over here. And do you see
this over here? This is the padding. This is used
to add padding. So remember this one, okay, let me
actually change it to a default. Like that. There
we go. So if you remember, this is going to add
padding to all four sides. But you don't want this
behavior, you just want to add padding to let's
say that left and right, okay, in order to do it
manually, you're going to click this over here and
using this option over here, you can manually add
padding over here. Let's say that I want to add 50
pixels of padding to the left side. There we go,
boom, it's going to add padding to just to the
left side. Okay, now let's say that now let's
say that I want to add padding to the top, okay?
Top How much are let's say the 25 pixels, okay,
so I'm gonna come over here and write 25, like
this, and hit enter. Now look, I have 25 pixels
of padding and the top 50 pixels of padding on the
left, if you want to individually set the padding,
this tool is very helpful. Alright, then now let's
experiment how to make a button using the auto
layout. Okay, so I'm going to delete this from
here, okay, I'm going to make a button like this,
look at that, you see this button over here, I'm
going to make it I mean, I'm going to duplicate
it. Okay, so I'm going to come over here, and the
very first thing that I can do is I'm gonna write
text over here like this, okay, I'm gonna write
after selecting T. And let me show you the steps,
okay, you're going to hit t on your keyboard,
or you're going to select this over here, okay?
So t like this, and then and click over here on
your screen, I mean, on your frame, again, you're
going to right button, bu TT o and like this
button, okay? So, I'm going to convert this button
text to full capital letters. Okay, so I'm going
to come over here like this, and I'm gonna select
this option over here. Okay, look at that. Now,
what I'm going to do is I'm going to directly add,
I'm going to directly add or layout, look at this,
okay, I'm going to right click over here and add
order lab, or what you can do is you can, you can
click shift plus a like this look, shift and a,
now look, oral layout is added to our button.
Okay, in order to see that, what you have to do
is we're going to click this over here, and then
you see this field over here. I'm going to click
this over here like this, and I'm going to change
the fill color to black, okay, 0000, like this,
and look at that, it got converted to very dark
black. Okay, now, I'm going to come over here,
and then I'm going to select Ctrl on
my keyboard, and then right click,
I'm in left, click over here, and then I'm going
to select the text, okay, the text is selected, or
what you can do is you can come over here on this
frame, okay, this frame gets highlighted in blue,
and then look at this frame, I mean, this oral
layout frame, okay, and inside this frame,
we have the bottom, okay, you're going to click
this over here, or you can directly control and
then left click over here, then is going to
select the text, okay, and then you see this
color over here, I'm going to change it to white,
okay, f f, f f, six times f, like this look,
is gonna bring back my buttons. Okay, now let's
say that I want to add some padding to the left
and to the right side of one button. So how do I
do this. And before doing that, what you have to
normally do is we have to select this over here,
and then you have to select this, which means that
you want the text to be at the very center of
your bottom. Otherwise, what happens is, if you
want to resize your button, let's say that I want
to resize Mazzuca that the text is aligned to the
very left it is not moving, okay, if I resize it
like this, look, it is not moving anywhere. Okay,
controls that control that. Now, if I set it to
the very center like this, if I resize my model
anywhere, anyhow, wherever I wish, like that, look
at it, this text will stay at the very center,
we're here like that, look at that, I can move it
anywhere I want, okay, controls that. Now, let's
say that I want to individually add some padding,
okay, I'm going to select over here. And then
let's say I want to select padding of 30 pixels
on the left in the right, okay, 30 over here,
gap, I mean, enter 30 over here, hit enter like
that, look at that, we have 10 pixels of padding,
your top bottom, and 30 pixels of padding on the
left and right. Also, I'm going to show you how
you're going to utilize these two buttons over
here to make responsive layout for your desktop,
tablet, mobile Web Designs more quickly
and efficiently. So keep watching,
I hope you understood how to align your content
and make buttons using the auto layout feature.
Now I'm going to show you this feature that is
left to discuss this feature over here. Okay,
so this is the vertical direction and
this is the horizontal direction. Okay,
I'm going to remove this real quick. And look at
this over here. Do you see this layout over here?
Do you see these cards over here? How is this
stacked? This is stacked on a horizontal line. And
if you see the mobile version, the mobile design
Look at this. It is stacked vertically like this.
So how do we do this very quickly, easily and
efficiently. Okay, so I'm going to come to this
Dexter version over here and then I'm going to
copy this one to the right side. Okay. Or perhaps
let's say I want to copy this over here. Okay.
Like that. I'm going to extend this like this,
okay? And then I'm going to click one time over
here, okay? And then out, press the out button
on your keyboard, okay? like this and then drag
it over here like this, look at that. Okay? So,
auto layout is also enabled on this one. Okay? If
you see the right panel over here, you see this
orange, you see this auto layout is enabled,
okay? Do you see this horizontal direction
it is enabled, which means that our cards will
act like this, okay, it's going to act on the
horizontal line is gonna layout on the horizontal
line, what you're saying that we want it to be
on the vertical line, which means that we
want to make it for the mobile version. Okay,
what we're gonna do is, we're going to click
it over here like this. Okay, boom, we made the
layout of workouts for the mobile version, look
at that, how quickly I made it. So the mobile has
small screen. Okay, so I have to resize it like
this. Let's say that, I'm going to come over here,
and then I'm going to hit the K. Or what you
can do is you can come over here and then
select the scale version over here. Okay, I'm
going to hit K over here, like this, and then
click this. And then I'm going to resize it like
this, look at that. It got resized, if you want
to resize even further, according to your screen,
which is normally small, like this, look at that.
You can, you can adjust the width and height
accordingly to your needs, okay, like this, using
the scale isn't isn't the scale to now look at
this side by side comparison how easy and quickly
I made layout from a mobile version from the
desktop version. This is the desktop version over
here. And this is the mobile version over here, by
the way to see the content inside this card, this
chemistry, this button over here, this image over
here, all of them are using the auto layout. And I
have used auto layout to align the content at the
very center. If I see if I select one card like
this, look at that. Okay, I have selected this
card over here. So look at this content over here,
okay, if I come to this auto layout, look, all the
content has 19 pixels of padding, I mean gaps in
between. And then if I select this one over here,
then you can see that the content is aligned to
the very center like this, look at that, I really
hope that you understood the auto layout feature.
The next feature that I want to talk about is
the layout grid. So you can select any frame you
want across all these pages, either the desktop,
tablet, mobile or anything, we are going to find
this frames, Okay, I'm gonna send the first one
as an example. Okay. And then you're going to find
this over here, the layout grid. So when is this
used, if you want to plan your content, I mean,
if you want to make a web design responsive for
the next top, tablet, mobile, etc, you need to
plan your content, right? So using this, you can
plan your content. Let me show you a demo. Okay,
so I'm gonna use the i button over here, I'm gonna
click this, this is used to hide that layout,
okay, like this, look at that, okay, and this
minus sign is used to delete that layout.
And this plus sign is used to add the layer, I
mean, the layout grid, okay. So look at this,
what is written over here, five columns are okay,
so if you count over here, 12345, we have five,
I mean, five grid columns, okay. So if you click
over here, like this, now, what is this, this
didn't count, okay, you can increase the number of
columns over here, you can also select the color
and then you can set the opacity over here like
this as well. So I'm going to click over here
like this. And then look at this, we have this
option on the columns, we can also change it to
grids like this, and you can see these little dots
over here like a graph paper, okay? You see this?
thin lines like this, okay? This pattern, okay?
And so this is the grid. Alright, so if you want
to change it to, let's say, columns, or sorry,
rows, you can also do it like this. Look at that.
It changed from columns to rows like this.
Now let's change it back to columns, okay,
like this. I'm going to click over here and then
columns like this. Now look, how many columns
do we have? 12345, right. So look at this over
here, we have five columns over here, and over
this margin over here, 50 pixels of margin. So if
I zoom in over here, so look at this over here,
you see this first column over here, the gap
between the first column and the start of our
screen over here is 50 pixels. This is the
gap. I mean, this is the margin over here.
And regarding the gutter, we see we have 30 pixels
of gutter over here, okay? Now look at this, this
is the gutter, okay? I mean, the space between the
columns, okay, this is 30 pixels. Now, the best
example that I can give you at the moment is this
one, wait a minute, this layout over here you see
this one over here offered courses. This has three
cards, how many cards, three cards, which means
that we can stack them on three columns. Okay,
let me show you a mess like this. And look at
this over here. Okay, I'm gonna and now I'm going
to click this button over here to show you how the
layout grid is working. Okay, so look In this,
how many layers? I mean, how many columns do we
have? We have three columns and three cards. Okay,
so how many how much gap? Did I put between the?
I mean, how much margin did I put? Okay, so I can
see it over here like this, okay? Look at this, we
have three columns. So it's gonna be highlighted
three over here, and the color is this one red.
And this is used to change the transparency. Okay?
So if I increase the size like this, look at that,
it gets much red. Okay, I'm going to change it to
10% so that it is visible. I mean, both the layout
grid and content becomes visible, okay. 10% is a
sweet spot. And we have margin of 77 pixels. Okay.
On the left and the right, and gutter, we have
turned to pixels. A couple of seconds ago, I told
you that this layout grid is used to plan your
content when you're making responsive websites,
I mean, Web Designs. Okay, let me show you a
demo. Okay. This is the best example that I
can give you right now. So I'm going to click
this over here. And look at this over here,
how many columns do we have? We have three columns
over here with 77 pixels of margin on the left and
the right and then we have 32 pixels of gutter,
okay? So this is, you see this gap over here.
Okay, white colored space between the red and our
start off screen over here. This is 77 pixels of
margin, okay. And this gutter over here, you see
this white color over here? This is 32 pixels.
This is the gutter. Okay? So this is the desktop
layout. Okay, how many columns do we have? We have
three columns and three columns are stacking three
cards. In case of the mobile layout, look at this,
okay, I'm going to click over here, this mobile
on the page section and look at this, how many
columns Do we have, we have just one single column
and this single column is stacking how many cards,
three cards because we have less space, less space
on the mobile version? Okay, so I'm going to click
on this and then I'm going to inspect that layout
grid. Okay. So I'm going to click over here. Now
look, how many columns do we have? We have just
one single column. And how many margin Do we
have 20 pixels of margin. Now for zooming, look at
this, this space over here is 20 pixels of margin.
Okay, and this is the mobile layout. If we
want to add layout grid on your frame, what
you have to do is you're going to select F, okay,
on your keyboard like this, and then you're gonna
drag it like this, look at this, we have a frame,
okay, if you want to add that layout grid, you're
going to select this like this and look at this
over here, you see this layout grid over here,
you're going to click this over here like this,
the plus sign, okay, then it's going to add this
pattern over here. If you want to change it,
then you're going to click this over here. And
then you're going to change it to columns or
rows over here, according to your needs. Okay.
I hope you understood how to use the layout grid.
Alright, now I'm going to discuss about the
constraints properly. Okay, in order to discuss
about the constraints provided, you're going to
come to this section, I mean, this page over here,
responsive test. Okay, so you have noticed
this before, okay, if you click any element
like this, then you're going to find this
constraints property over here. I'm going
to discuss about this one. Okay. This is used to
test whether your design is responsive or not.
So I use the constraints provided along with
the plugin named breakpoints. Okay, this is a
plug in over here, I have actually included this
section for you to test. So you're going to come
over here. Okay. So do you see this guy's over
here? I'm going to zoom in a little bit. Okay.
I'm gonna come over here you see this. These
are our breakpoints for one four pixel is the
breakpoint for the mobile version. Okay. 767 168
pixels is the breakpoint for the tablet version.
This is the breakpoint for the laptop version. And
this one is the Dexter version. Okay, now look,
what happens if I resize it? So I'm going to click
this over here. Okay. look very carefully. Look at
this, the constraint property is working. When
I resize the window like this, look at this,
our content is at the very center, we're here.
Don't worry, we're going to recreate the results.
Okay, just look what happens. So when it comes to
the tablet breakpoint, now look what happens. Now,
if I now if I cross the tablet break? Well, now
what happens? Here is the tablet breakpoint. So
I'm going to cause the tablet breakpoint. Okay,
like this, look at that. Look, our design changed
because the plugin named breakpoints, and if I
resize it like this, now look what happens. We
have some gaps over here, okay, and the content
is actually at the very center over here. So if
I resize it even further, now look what happens.
The font size changes and the content increases in
size. Like that. Look at that. Let me actually
resize it again. Okay, now look what happens
when that small large is the laptop. This is
the tablet version. This is the laptop version,
tablet version, mobile version over here, mobile
tablet, laptop, the constraint properties used
over here. Okay, I'm going to delete this over
here real quick. Okay, so I'm gonna come over
here. Okay. Wait a minute. Now look at this.
This is the design for the laptop version. This
is the tablet version over here and this
one is the most Version over here. Okay,
so I'm gonna just focus on the mobile version over
here like this, wait a minute, there we go. Okay,
so I'm gonna bring my options over here. And then
what I'm going to do is I'm going to select all my
elements together, okay? Like this. And then I'm
gonna group it together like this Ctrl G. Now,
if we select this one over here, and if
you notice over here, now you see this,
this blue color is highlighted, and this one over
here as well. This is the top and this one is the
left, okay, which means that if you resize the
window like this, wait a minute, like this, then
what will happen is your content will be focused,
your content will be locked on the left top, like
this, look at that. But let's say that you want
it to be on the bottom. Right. So how will you
do this? control that Okay, I'm going to select
this I mean, the entire content section and I'm
gonna select this one. Okay, bottom, right. Now
look, what happens if I resize the window. Okay,
now, look, what happened is gonna stay focused. I
mean, he's gonna stay fixed on the bottom, right?
Okay. Okay, now I'm going to select this
one. And I'm gonna drag it down like this,
look at that. Our content is getting fixed on the
bottom right. Now, let's say that I want it to be
on the bottom left, what will I do, I'm going to
do the same thing, okay, I'm going to come to that
constraints property. Wait a minute, there's one,
okay, then then I'm going to select a bottom left,
okay, I'm going to just click this over here, or
what I can do, I can just click this overhead and
select the left option like this. Okay, and
now look what happens, we resize the window,
I'm gonna drag this over here. Now look,
it's gonna stay focused on the bottom left.
Like that. So in the case of testing my
responsiveness of my Web Designs, what I do
is I'm gonna select all my content, and then I'm
gonna center both horizontally and vertically like
this. Okay, now look, what happens if I resize
the window like this, look at that. Okay, it stays
at the exact center like this. Okay, I
do it for all my contents, wait a minute,
let me actually resize it. And I'm going to select
all this content over here like this Ctrl G.
I have grouped them together, I'm
going to select this and I'm gonna
enable this option. Okay, center center. Same
thing for the version as well like this, okay,
Ctrl, G, and then center center like
this. Now, there is a plugin named
breakpoints, okay, I'm going to right click over
here and then select this plug in, okay, you
didn't have to do anything, just look what I do.
Okay. And if you want to test it out, I'm going
to include this section over here, you're gonna
come to this section, and then test it on your own
how the system works, okay, so I'm going to select
this plugins option over here, and then I want to,
and then I'm going to select this breakpoints,
like this. And there is going to give me this
little window over here. Okay, I'm going to
select new adaptive layout like this. And then
I'm going to define a breakpoint over here,
and I'm going to keep it over here as well.
And let me actually, alright,
then, I'm going to select this one.
And then I'm going to right over here for one,
four, which is the mobile display breakpoint,
okay, and then I'm going to right over
here 768, which is the tablet screen,
and then I'm going to click this plus sign over
here, okay, and then I'm going to right over here,
1024 pixels, laughter version, and then plus over
here, again, we're here 1440 pixels, 1440 pixels,
which is the Dexter version, okay, now look
at this plus sign over here, I'm gonna click
this and I'm gonna select this mobile layout, like
this plus sign over here, I'm going to select this
tablet version. Okay, I'm going to select this
over here, and I'm gonna select this laptop as
well. Okay. Now, this is the result we got so far.
Okay, now, this content is at the very center. If
I resize it, wait a minute, let's actually select
this and then guess what happens? Look what
happens. Okay? Oh, I actually need to increase
the width over here as well like this looking at
I mean height, I need to increase the
height like this. Now look what happens
if I resize the window like this, we're gonna
see the mobile version. Okay, this is the tablet
version. And this one is the laptop
version. The constraints tool. And the
break point to both of them are very handy
if you want to test out your responsiveness
of a web design. So I'm going to keep it as it is
so that you can come and practice over here, okay.
Alright, now I'm going to talk about a tool
called components. Okay? So look at this
over here, this footer over here. This is
actually a component. Okay, we are gonna,
you and me together, we're going to change this
social media icons with this one over here.
I'm going to come to this assets over here and
look at this social media icons over here. Okay,
we're going to replace this. So we're going to
replace this one with these ones over here. Okay,
but before that, let's actually test what does
our components do? Okay, so I'm going to come
to the left side over here, and I'm going to
draw a frame F and then like this, look at that.
Let's say that I'm going to write some dummy text
over here Okay, like this. A B, C, D, okay? Ctrl
A and I'm going to change the size to let's say
100 pixels, okay? Like this, look at that. Okay,
I'm going to change the font weight to regular.
Okay? Now look what happens if I copy this to,
let's say three times, okay? This is the second
time, this is the third time over here. Okay,
I'm going to zoom in a little bit like
this. Now look what happens, let's say that
one of many benefits of the components function
is that it helps you to stop repeating the same
design again, and again, they the day, the day
and night difference between copying and pasting
the same thing and using the components, okay,
let's say that I have copied and paste it three
times over here, okay, 123. Let's say that I want
to remove the C, okay, I don't need the C. Okay,
so what so what I have to do is, I'm going to
select this over here, and I'm going to remove the
C over here like this, okay? Same thing, I have
to repeat how many times three times one time,
two time over here like this, okay, and
three time over here like this, look at that.
But if I use a component that, wait
a minute, let me actually remove this
from here. And I'm going to write ABCD
over here, okay? If I right, oh, sorry.
Now, if I'm making a component, how to make a
component, okay, I'm going to click this button
over here, create component, or what I can do is
I can right click over here and create component
like this. Now, this is a component over here, you
can see you can tell it vice, you can tell it by
looking at this icon over here. Or you can also
you can also tell it by looking at this highlight
over here, a component is highlighted in purple
color, okay? Now look what happens if I copy from
this component, okay? All and then click over here
and then drag like this, okay? Now, look at this,
over here, look at my layers over here. This
is a diamond shape, which means that this is
an instance of the parent component, this is the
parent, this is an instance. Okay, I'm gonna do
it the same like this. Again, they say I want to
do it more three times, okay, like this look at.
And let's say that I have to change it, I have to
remove the C, what will I do, I have to remove it
six times, I have to do the same thing six times.
But if I use a component like this one, now look
what happens if I remove the C from the parent
component like this, look at that, I removed the
C, the C is removing all my six designs over here,
look at that, by just changing this one over here,
and nothing else. Everything is changed. This is
the main selling point of the components. Okay,
so I'm going to delete this from here. And
look at this design over here. I will look
at my footer over here. This social media icon is
it is blue in color, it doesn't go with our team.
If I come to our color palette over here, look at
this. This is my color palette over here. Okay,
you can check the hex value over here as well
look at this hex value and this hex value as well.
All right, no, this doesn't go with our color over
here. This is blue color, light blue color. So I'm
going to change this to black and white. Okay,
this one over here, this, if we come to this
assets over here, there's one Okay, now what I'm
going to do is I'm going to click this frame over
here and then hit Alt on my keyboard like this,
and then I'm going to drag it like this. Okay,
it's going to get copied, and then I'm going
to right click, and then I'm going to select
this option over here, move page to Dexter.
Okay, I'm going to come to text over here,
wait a minute, there we go, we have our
design over here, you actually need to,
you actually need to zoom out a little bit
so that you can see where the frame is.
Okay, like this, I got my frame over here.
All right now. Now I'm gonna select this one,
this. Now I'm going to select this tutor
option over here by double clicking over here,
and then double clicking again, like this.
Now I can see the exact width and height of my
tutor over here. I went to the icon over here,
this for 8.81 pixel. So I'm going to copy this
from here like this Ctrl C. And then what I'm
going to do is I'm going to resize all of my
media icons, okay, like this, I'm gonna select
this over here, and then I'm going to hit
cake on my keyboard, okay, like this, I
can resize it like this, look at that.
Now what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna lock it over
here, like this is the constraints property.
And then Ctrl V, if I paste it over here, then
it then this value will automatically get applied
on my height over here as well. Okay, so I'm
gonna select enter like this. Now look at that.
It gave me accurate calculations. So I'm
going to drag it over here, wait a minute,
over here like this. By the way, this folder over
here is the main parent component, okay? Which
means that if we change anything over here, then
all the children that all the children components,
I mean, all the instances will get changed as
well look at this, I placed the social media icon,
the Facebook, black and white over here on the
parent component, and it got applied over here
on the children component. Same thing goes for
all the children components as well look at
that. We have this Facebook icon over here. Now
I'm going to delete this one over here. Okay,
the blue colored one. So what I'm going
to do is I'm going to come over here,
and then I'm going to double click over here.
And then I'm going to delete like this. So it
got removed. And same thing got removed from all
the parent and children components as well look at
that, we'll have the social media icons over here.
Same thing for all the footer instances. Okay,
so I'm going to come back over here, and I'm
going to resize them also in a similar manner,
I'm going to hit K and then resize it like
this, look at that. And then I'm going to hit
this constraints property. And then I'm going to
paste the value that I have copied, okay, Ctrl V,
enter, look at that. So I'm going to select
it together, and I'm going to drag it on here,
like this. Okay, now, what I'm going to do
is I'm going to arrange a series like this.
And then I'm going to hit Shift plus a, after
dragging, after selecting all this, okay,
like this, shift a, and then I can adjust the gap
over here like this, let's say I want a gap of 10
pixels, okay? I change the mind, I'm gonna select
it, like this, there we go. I can also change
the stroke as well. Okay, if I select Ctrl on my
keyboard, and if I select this stroke over here,
like this, then it's gonna select me this,
look at this, I'm going to change the to.
Okay, and I'm going to do the same thing
over here, hit Ctrl on your keyboard,
and then hit Ctrl on your keyboard and select this
circle over here. And then change the to from 3.5
to like this, look at that, it looks beautiful.
Double click over here and then follow the orange
colored guides, okay? Look, our content is look,
our social media icons are aligned the left
according to those texts over there. Okay,
now if I inspect all of my, let me actually delete
this from here. Nine now if I inspect all of my
children instances, look at this, the same thing
got applied over here, because that is because we
change the parent component. All children's,
all children instances are bound to change.
Look at that, I really hope that you understood
how to use this useful tool named components.
Congratulations, guys, we're done discussing
all the essential tools of figma. Now we're
going to start making our web design for the
desktop version. Let's get started. But the
first question is, how will we practice? Alright,
then we're going to practice like this over here,
we're going to draw our frames, okay, like this.
And then we're going to copy this design on our
practice case over here. As a beginner, this is
completely fine to copy others works and designs
because this is part of the learning process. So
I'm going to delete this one here like this. And
then what I'm going to do is I'm gonna move
this to the right side, okay, and then I'm
going to draw a frame over here, like this, follow
along with me, I'm gonna hold my shift, and then
I'm gonna select the names like this, okay, I will
name the frame like this. Alright, and then I'm
going to select the fingers. And then I'm going to
drag it over here like this. There we go. Now what
I'm going to do some zoom in over here, okay,
whatever. This is my color palette over here.
I'm going to keep it over here. There we go. And
then I'm going to make a frame over here. Okay,
so I'm gonna select my F, which is frame to locate
F. And then I'm gonna select this over here, okay,
dekstop. And then this one dekstop, which has
a dimension of 440 pixels in width, like this,
look at that. Okay, I'm going to keep it over here
like this, the first thing that I'm going to do is
I'm going to make grid layouts. Okay? So what I'm
going to do is I'm going to select this element
over here, okay? And then I'm gonna select this
little icon over here, okay, so that I can see the
grids over here. And then I'm going to select this
so that I can better see what is the margin and
what is the gutter over here, okay, you can see
figure, we can see 50 pixels of margin over here.
But let's say that in certain scenarios, you
cannot actually see how much is the margin over
here. So what will you do in this case, in this
case, what you can do is, let me actually show
you a trick over here. So I'm going to come
over here, okay, you see my text over here.
And this gap over here, I'm going to draw a
rectangle over here, let me actually show you
Okay, I'm going to hit R. And then I'm going to
draw a little rectangle over here, and I'm gonna
keep it over here like this, and it's gonna snap
inside this, let me actually zoom in a little bit,
so that you can better see how this is working.
All right, so look at this rectangle over here,
and then I'm gonna stretch it to this till this
side over here, okay, like this, wait a minute,
like this, look at that this rectangle is filling
that gap over here. Now if I select this over
here, and if I inspect this rectangle, you can
see that this rectangle is 50 pixels in width,
which means that here is 50 pixels of gap.
So now what I'm going to do is I'm going to
remove this rectangle from here. Alright, then
I'm going to come to my main design over here,
I'm in the practice case, and then I'm gonna give
this one over here, auto layout grid, okay, like
this. And then I'm going to change it to columns
like this, okay? And then I'm going to give here
how many pixels of margin 50 because we found out
to the rectangle that it is 50 pixels of margin,
okay, like that. And let's actually see what
we have specified in the grid like this. Okay.
And 30 pixels of gutter, Okay, there we go like
that 30 pixels over here, if you hold shift and
up, if you hold shift and then press the up arrow
bottom, then it's gonna change 10 scale at a time
like this look, it is 20 3040 5060 7080 while I'm
holding the shift, but if you release the shift,
and if you use the arrow sign, I mean up arrow
sign, then what do we have? This is gonna change
one pixel, one pixel like that is 80 pixels, okay?
8180 280-384-8586 is gonna take a lot of time,
so I'm going to use the shift, okay, I'm going
to jump to 36. And then I'm going to write 30.
We're here like this. There we go. Looks quite
perfect. Now, now we're gonna make this navbar
over here. Okay, in order to inspect this
element, what I'm going to do is I'm going to
select Ctrl on my keyboard, okay? And then I'm
gonna click over here like this. Now, you can
see all the properties over here, do you see this?
The color, the font family, the font, weight, font
size, etc. Okay, so look at this, it is 90 pixels.
So I'm going to copy this over here like this
Ctrl C, I'm going to come over here and then and
then hit t on your keyboard like this T, and then
click over here, okay, and write a do or sorry,
they do.io. And the font family is four pins,
which is correct over here, change it to semi
bold over here, like this, and then select 90
over here like this. 90, okay. Okay, I'm going to
keep it over here like this. Okay, do you see this
orange colored guides is going to snap like this,
okay, so you don't have to do anything manually.
Next thing that we have is home teachers contact
assigning options. By the way, you have this
dekstop typographic guide over here, which you can
follow. Okay, so this logo is 90 pixels over here,
the nav items, each of these nav
items are 47 pixels in size. Okay,
so I'm going to come over here, I'm going
to hit t on my keyboard like this T,
click, and I'm going to right
put them over here, okay,
same thing, I'm going to copy it four times,
like this 123, and then four. Okay, I'm going
to write over here, teachers. And I'm gonna write
over here, contact us. And over here, signing,
we also need to change the form way,
we also need to change the font weight,
in order to inspect the font weight, I'm gonna
come over here on the original design. And then
I'm gonna click Ctrl. on my keyboard, click like
this, look at this, we have regular and 47 pixels,
also the font size, we have regular font weight,
47 pixels, font size, and look at this, the font
families revolt, okay, so I'm going to come over
here, like this, and I'm going to select all of
them together, how will I do this, look at that,
I'm gonna drag all of them together like this,
select all of them together like this. And
I'm going to right over here, 47, okay, Enter.
And then I'm going to write regular over here
like this, look at that. And then I'm going
to right over here Roboto, because the font
is rowboat over there on the original design
room for two, there we go. Now the next thing that
I'm going to do is I'm going to select all of them
together like this, and then shift a or what I can
do is I'm going to right, I'm going to right click
over here and then add auto layout. Or you can
also do it by using the shortcut shift plus a,
I'm going to do it over here like this. Alright.
Now I'm going to click this over here, because it
should be on the horizontal line like this, look
at that, there we go. And then I'm going to click
this over here. And I'm going to select this so
that it always I mean, all the text should remain
at the center. We're here, both horizontally
and vertically inside this frame, like this,
look at that. And now the next thing that I'm
going to do is I'm going to snap it to this side
over here of my great lines, okay, like that,
look at that. There we go. It snaps like this.
All right now. Now if we look at the original
design over here, okay, if I select this over
here, by double clicking over here like this,
then you can see that we have 50 pixels of gap,
which means that it should be 50 pixels of gap as
well, between that between the nav items. So I'm
going to click this over here like this, and it is
set to 93. So I'm going to change it to 50 pixels.
There we go. I'm gonna start I'm going to snap
it on the grid lines over here like this again,
and what I'm gonna do is I'm going to select
both the logo and the nav items like this.
Oh, by the way, you should change the home text
to medium Okay, you're gonna click this over here
and then from regular to medium like this, okay,
because in the original design over here, it is
said to medium as well because this is the current
design. Alright then. So I'm going to click both
of them together like this and then shift plus a.
Now look at that, whenever items are shifted at
the top in order to bring it at the very middle at
the very center. What I'm going to do is I'm going
to click this over here Okay, and then select this
over here. Now look, it looks exactly carbon copy
of the original document. original design. Now
look at this over here on the original design,
we Have this rectangle over here, okay? I
mean underline over here, how do we recreate
this? Okay, follow along with me. Okay, so I'm
gonna click this over here and then I'm gonna
lock it, I'm going to lock my content like this.
Okay, I'm going to zoom in over here like this,
I'm going to select the Rectangle Tool by
pressing the R button on my keyboard are
and then I'm going to select, I mean, I'm
going to make a rectangle over here like this.
I'm going to resize it like this so that I can
see the orange guides over here. Okay, the orange
guides are snapping like this, look at that, I'm
gonna change it like this are seven, seven pixels
in height, and 126 pixels in width. Okay, now I'm
going to change the corner radius like this, I'm
gonna write 10 over here. Okay, there we go. And
in order to change the color, what I'm going to do
is I'm gonna select this, okay, while selecting
that, look at this color palette over here. Okay,
I'm going to select this color from here,
and then this eye button over here, okay,
like that. And then I'm going to select this
one, look at that, I have successfully changed
the color and also made this underline I'm going
now items, there we go, it looks quite the same as
this one. Now the next thing that we need is the
image, this asset over here. Okay, so, so so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna come to this assets
page over here, okay, and then look at this, we
have the asset over here. So what I'm going to do
is I'm gonna select this and then press the Alt,
key word, press the Alt key on my keyboard like
this, and then I'm going to drag it like hit,
I'm going to drag it like this over here. And
I'm going to right click over here and then
move to page dekstop. Like this, then is
gonna send me to the next page over here,
what you actually need to search where the asset
has moved to, okay, by zooming out like this,
and there we go, we have our asset over
here like this. Okay, now look at this,
we have some unnecessary gap around our
illustration. Just look at that, too. Okay,
so I'm going to select this over here. Now look
at all of these files over here. Do you see this
on welcome number two, this is a frame. Okay, so
look at this, we have so many vectors over here,
I'm going to select the very last one like this,
this one, okay, I'm going to select the very last
one over here. And then what I'm going to do is
I'm going to literally delete this from here,
delete. Now look at that, that whitespace went
away, I'm gonna select this text over here, okay,
I mean, I'm gonna select the whole frame, like
this. Now, look, we still have some gaps around
our illustration. Now, what you're gonna do is
you're gonna select this over here, you see this,
okay? Like this, and then select group over here.
Now look, all the whitespace went away like that.
So I'm going to bring it over here like this.
Now the next thing that we're going to do is
we're going to copy the width and height of this
image, okay, by double clicking over here. Now, do
you see this. So the first thing that we can do is
we can either copy both of them together and then
paste them on this illustration one by one. But
if you want to save some, a little bit of time,
what you can do is you can just select this one,
and then copy the only the width, okay? Ctrl C,
and then you select this one, and then you click
this constraints proportion, okay, like this,
and then paste it over here like this. Now, what
it will do is it's gonna scale our illustration,
proportionately, it is going to
follow the proportional measurement.
And also is going to change our height
as well according to the proportional
measurement. So these are I'm going to click
into like this. There we go. Now look, it looks
as similar as this one, you see this. I'm keeping,
I'm keeping both of them on top of another. Look,
it looks quite the same. Okay, so I'm going to
bring it over here. And then I'm going to take
the help of this orange colored guide and snap
my image over here on my grids like that, look at
that. Alright, now regarding the text, how do we
write the text, okay, so I'm going to double click
over here and double click over here, again, like
this now is going to copy the text, okay? Ctrl C,
you don't have to write anything, okay? Just copy
the text. Okay, so I'm going to come over here and
then T, click over here, okay, Ctrl V. So I have
copied the text over here. And along with that,
it changed those these properties over here as
well. Alright, so I'm going to keep it over here
like this. And I'm going to come back over here
like this, double click over here. And if you want
to copy something quickly, what you're going to do
is you're going to double click over here, okay?
And then you're gonna hit alt, on your keyboard
out and then drag it over here like this, you're
gonna, it got copied very quickly like this. Now
regarding the button, how to create a button,
I'm going to use the auto layout, okay, so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to come over here and
then Firstly, I'm going to hit the T, okay? Click,
and I'm going to write logging. Okay. Sorry,
log in. Now let's see the properties of this text
over here. Okay. Ctrl click like this. 45 pixels.
Bold rowboat okay. So I'm gonna
write rowboat over here. Book door
and bowled over here. 45 here as well.
Enter. Now look what I'm gonna do. I'm
gonna click this over here and then right click
Add Auto Layout like this, look at that. Okay,
now we have it in visible background. So I'm going
to click it over here. And do you see this field
over here? I'm going to click this field.
I'm going to select this over here. Okay?
And do you see my color palette over here? This is
actually not complete black it is actually it has
a color. Okay, do you see this color over here,
it is this color. So I'm going to select this
again. And the field, I'm gonna select this one
and this eye button over here. And then I'm gonna
click over here like this, it got very dark. So
I'm going to double click over here on the text or
control, click like this, okay, and then this
is set to black, I'm going to select this and f,
f, f, f six times, or three times, you
can also read it three times f, f, f,
enter, look at that. We have white colored
text inside our black colored button. So I'm
going to click this over here. And I'm
going to set some border radius, okay?
I mean corner radius, let's say in pixels,
okay, let's actually see the original one,
it is actually 18 pixels, okay, and width is this
one. So I'm going to copy the width from here,
Ctrl C, and the height is 105 pixels, okay. And
I'm going to paste it over here, look at that,
you cannot actually change it over here. But in
this cases, what you can do is you can, you're
going to come over here and just drag it over
here like this a little bit, a little bit, not too
much. And you can see this, it got unlocked, and
the height is law. In order to unlock the type,
you're going to click over here like this, and
you're going to drag it like this. Look at that,
the height and width, both of them got unlocked.
Okay, so I'm going to pay the width over here.
Ctrl V, enter. Okay, don't worry, we're gonna
change the properties, okay, and the height
should be, wait a minute, it should be I guess,
70 to 105. Okay, we'll select this, and 105,
enter. Now, we need the text to be at the very
center, do you remember this property over here,
this little icon, I'm gonna select this, and
I'm gonna click this over here so that it gets
centered at the very middle, like this,
look at both horizontally and vertically.
We got our solution over here. Alright, so
I'm going to click the button over here,
and I'm going to right click, and I'm going to
replicate another model. How do I do this? All on
your keyboard and drag it like this, look at that.
And I'm gonna right over here, what? Come on,
tell me sign up. There's one. Okay. Wait a minute
sign up. Okay, so always, always turn this one on.
So that extra whitespace gets reduced. And the
bottom stays I'm in the bottom text remains at
the very center. Okay, so I'm going to click
it over here again, so that this is enabled,
okay, all the width is enabled. So what this does
is it removes all extra white spaces, so that your
button looks proportional aesthetic. So now look
at this, even if we have a buttons like this,
what we're going to do is we're going to use our
layout, okay, so I'm going to select both of them
together and shift plus a like this, look at that.
Okay, and then I'm going to click this over here,
and then center over here like this, so that it
always remains at the center. And look at this,
we also need to add some drop shadow to our
buttons. How do we do this, I'm going to click
it over here like this, and look at FX over here.
I'm gonna click it over here like this. Okay.
Now let's look at our original document, what is
the priority of our effect the drop shadow effect,
okay, so I'm going to select this button over
here like this, wait a minute, like this,
and then I'm going to select this drop shadow
over here. So they set to 10. On the x, y is 10.
And the blur is four over here. Okay, so I'm going
to come to this practice over here, and then I'm
gonna select the button, I'm gonna select this
drop shadow, I'm going to say they will have 10
like this, the blur is four, that's fine. And for
the wives should be 10, like this, there we go.
Now in order to transfer this blur radius to
this button over here, instead of doing it again,
instead of repeating the same thing, what you're
going to do is you're going to click over here,
double click over here, and then look at this,
I'm going to double click over here, and then
I'm going to right click over here and then copy,
paste. Okay, I'm going to copy the properties,
and I'm going to double click over here, and
right click, and then I'm going to paste the
properties over here like this, look at that,
I have successfully transferred the walk shadow
of the first button to the second button over
here like that we're gonna, this is how the copy
paste properties works. Okay, so far, so good. Now
let's look at the gap between the buttons on the
original document. Okay, so I'm gonna come over
here. Now, instead of looking at the oral layout,
what you can do is you can just select this
first second button over here, and then hold,
you hit all and wherever you place the mouse is
going to show that distance between that button
and the element like let's look at that. I'm going
to keep my mouse on the first button over here.
Let me show this to you again. Okay, so I'm going
to double click over here and double click again,
or just hit Ctrl on your keyboard and then
right click, left click sorry, like this. And
you're going to hit Alt on your keyboard,
okay, and you're going to place your mouse
on the first button over here now, look at this.
Let me actually zoom in, okay, look at this,
we have 53 pixels of gap between the first and
the second button. So I'm going to come over here,
as you remember that we have enable oral layout on
our buttons over here. So I'm going to click this
over here, and then I'm gonna come over here and
write 53 pixels of gap, okay, five, three, enter,
like that. Now, regarding the gap between our text
over here, and the text over here, I mean, the
first text and the second text, what you're going
to do is you're going to do the same thing, okay,
I'm going to come over here like this, I'm going
to Ctrl click like this, and then I'm going to hit
alt, on my keyboard, Alt, and then I'm gonna put
my mouse on this second test, we're gonna, we have
41 pixel, I can see 41 pixels of gap. So I'm going
to come over here. And instead of doing manually,
just select both of them together like this, and
shift plus a, and then you click this option.
And then you're going to do it like this.
Okay, you're gonna keep it in the middle,
middle left, like that. Okay, so how much was the
gap again? 41. Right? So I'm gonna come over here.
And do you see this option after clicking this
41, fix it like that. 41, enter, there we go.
Now let's look at the difference, I mean, the
distance between the buttons and the text,
okay, I'm going to select this button
over here. And then same process, okay,
all on your keyboard, and then select that text
over here like this, we've got 41 pixels as well.
So I'm going to come over here. And I'm going to
select this and a button like this, look at that,
and then shift plus a, now I'm going to write
41. Over here. And there we go. Look at that,
we have successfully copied the design, from the
main design to our practice case over here. Now we
actually need to align our content according
to these gaps and various properties, right,
so I'm going to click on here, okay, this block
over here, and then I'm gonna click Alt on my
keyboard, same process, right, so I'm gonna keep
the mouse at the bottom so that I can see the gap
between my screen and the content, we're gonna it
is 109 pixels over here, you see this 109 pixels.
So I'm gonna come back over here, click this and
Alt, I'm going to hit Alt on my keyboard, and then
I'm going to put my mouse over here like this,
look at that this is 200,000 pixels of gap between
this corner I'm in this window, and this content
over here. Okay, so what was the original one,
it was 109. So what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna drag it at the bottom like this,
okay, and then I'm going to test it again,
camera, click this over here and all.
And then I'm gonna put my mouse over here. Look,
it is 124, which means that I have to go a little
bit below, like that. Okay, let's test again,
all 204. So I'm going to click this. And then
on it five, press the up arrow on my keyboard,
okay, on it for it is currently on 104. Okay,
100 506 789, like that. And I'm
gonna select this over here, and Alt,
on my keyboard, put my mouse over here, look
at this, this perfect 109 pixels over here,
regarding our image over here, let's fix that
as well. So I'm going to come over here and I'm
going to select this image over here by double
clicking over here. And I'm going to press Alt
on the keyboard, Alt, and then I'm going to put
the mouse over here. 167 pixels over here, okay,
so I'm going to come over here, back over
here and then drag it at the bottom, okay,
and then I'm gonna select old, look at 140 pixels,
okay? So I'm going to click this over here,
shift and up arrow shift up, so it's going to move
10 pixels, okay, so it's currently 150 161 234567,
I have pressed seven times my up arrow. Now look
at that. I'm going to click this over here. And
alt, I'm going to put my mouse over here like
that, because 167 pixels of gap between our image
I'm in illustration and the bottom screen. Now
we're going to the original design over here. Do
you see these lovely doodles over here? Do you see
this little flex over here, how to recreate them?
Let me show you. Okay, so I'm gonna zoom out
and I'm going to come to this assets page over
here. Okay. Now look, now look, I have actually
included this flex illustration over here, okay,
so I'm gonna leave this and I'm gonna copy this,
like this, Alt, drag like this, okay? Right click,
move page to desktop. Okay, so I'm gonna come
to next over here, zoom out and look at and look
where the file is. Okay, the file is over here. I
mean, that frame is over here. Okay? So I'm going
to click it over here like this. And I'm going to
bring it back over here like this. Wait a minute.
There we go. Now look, I'm going to
zoom in into the main file, okay?
Like this. Now look at that. We have this triangle
over here, circle over here, and then this wave
pattern over here, how to recreate that. So I'm
going to come to this flakes image over here.
And first of all, what was it triangle, okay, so
I'm gonna copy a triangle from here. Look at that.
We have a triangle over here. So I'm going to hit
Ctrl on my keyboard and then click over here. Like
this, okay that I have selected this Okay, so I'm
gonna right now I'm gonna hit the old keyboard,
copy. Okay, Alt, and then I'm gonna drag it from
here like that. Look at the deuces, you'll see
what is on my hand over here, I have copied it.
So I'm going to paste it over here directly on my
practice image over here, okay, like this,
I'm going to release my mouse, and then I'm
going to use the Alt key, there we go. Now the
next thing is, I have this circle over here, okay.
Now in order to make the circle, look at
the circle over here, I'm gonna select this,
control, click, and then alt, drag like this.
Okay, now, I'm going to come over here, and I'm
going to select this over here, and then we're
gonna enter, increase the size a little bit how
to do that, I'm going to hit k on my keyboard, and
then I'm going to drag it like this a little bit,
and then it's going to become a little bit bigger.
Okay, now, what is, what do we have, we have this
wave pattern over here. Okay, so I'm going to
come over here, and I'm gonna select this wave
over here. Now, it's, now look at this, this is a
little bit tricky, okay, so this wave is actually
multiple icons together, okay? If I control and
click over here, now look at this, this whole,
this whole wave doesn't get selected, okay, just
a single part gets selected. So in this case,
what should you do, you're gonna select, you're
gonna hit Ctrl, and shift both of them together,
okay, like this Ctrl, Shift, and then click like
this, click, click, click, click OK. And then
you're going to do what you're gonna do, you're
gonna press Ctrl G on your keyboard, which means
we're going to make it a group, or what you're
going to do is you're going to right click over
here, and then make it a group selection like
this, we're gonna, now this will behave like a
single element, instead of behaving like a
for individual, different elements. Okay,
now I'm gonna copy this from here, I'll click
OK. Now, I'm going to come back over here,
and I'm going to paste it over here, and then I'm
going to rotate it a little bit, okay, like that.
There we go. So it looks quite similar to this
one. Now I'm going to increase the gap between
them, like this, look at that. There we go. And,
and in order to change the color of this triangle
and his wave pattern, what you're gonna do is
you're gonna come over here on the main design,
Control, Shift, okay, click this one, and then
click this one, oh, sorry, you're gonna click on,
you're going to, you're going to click on here
first, okay, and then click this over here, that
eyedropper over here, and then you're gonna select
this one. Okay? So first of all, do I click this
over here, and then select this field over here,
then this eyedropper over here, okay, and then
you're gonna select this one, there we go. Look
at that, we have colored our flakes like that.
Okay, it looks quite similar to the original
design. This is our practice case. And this
is our design over here, look at that. Now, we
have a lot of flakes over here, error and our
image over here. And then we have a little bit
of over here. So I'm going to pause the video and
complete all of these doodles over here. In the
meantime, you do the same, you pause the video,
and you complete, you see the original file
over here. And then you make the same on
your practice case over here. Alright, so I'm
going to see you after a couple of minutes.
So we'll come back, I have completed all of
these doodles over here like this, look at that,
it looks quite the carbon copy of the original
design over here. Congratulations, we're done
creating our first web design. Now let's move on
to the next section. There's one over here. Okay,
we're gonna design this. So I'm gonna
come over here and create a frame F,
okay, and then next over here like this, look
at that, I have created this frame over here.
And then I'm going to come to this assets
over here. And let's select this one, okay,
this painter over here and then copy it from
here like this, and right click, send it to,
I mean, move to page, Dexter over here. Okay,
I'm going to come back to next over here.
And I'm going to search for the file. Where is
it? There is it we have our painter over here
like that guy, I'm gonna zoom in a little bit.
And the process is saying during the process,
you need to remove this white colored background.
So select this and look at this highlighted over
here. Okay, so I'm going to delete this vector
at the very bottom over here, right click left,
click over here, and then delete like that.
Look at that. And now we're going to select this
and then come over here on the frame selected to
group and it's going to remove all the unnecessary
whitespace. Okay, so I'm going to keep it over
here like that. Now I'm going to come over here,
and I'm going to inspect this element, what is it
by double. And now I'm going to come over here and
double click over here to inspect the element with
this width over here, 657. Click it over here,
Ctrl C, come back over here, like this,
click and then click this over here,
constraints proportions, okay, and then paste it
over here like this. Ctrl V, enter. There we go.
Like that. And I'm going to keep it at the center
like this and keep it at the center like this. Or
what you can do is you can just select this, Align
Horizontal Centers like this. Oh, sorry, not this.
One, this one Align Vertical fin just like this,
and it's gonna get snapped to the very center.
vertically. Okay? There we go. And regarding
this text over here, what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna Ctrl click over here like this, and
then I'm going to hit Alt on my keyboard,
drag it like this, okay, that I, I'm going to
keep it over here like this. Okay? Same thing.
I'm going to do the same thing for this text
over here as well. Ctrl, click, and then hit out,
Alt drag, like this, look at that. The process
is saying, you're going to click over here and
then alt and then move your mouse to this first
text. Okay? How many space Do you see is a pixels,
okay, so I'm going to come over here and shift
plus a shift a like this. And I'm going to keep
it at the very middle over here like this, I'm
gonna click this, there we go. And it should be
how much gap 80 pixels, right? It is currently set
to 51 pixels. So write a like this, okay, enter.
There we go. And then I'm gonna come back to this
button over here. So I already have this button,
we already created the buttons. So I'm gonna
come over here and double click on this button,
double click on this button, that will click again
over here. Okay, so I'm gonna copy this button by
writing by hitting alt, and then drag like this.
Okay, I'm gonna keep it over here, raise it, and
I'm gonna change the text to get started. Okay,
like that, double click over here, get started.
All right now looks quite good. So what I'm going
to do is I'm going to click on this button over
here, and then Alt on my keyboard. And then I'm
going to put a mouse on this text over this,
how much gap Do we have, we have 80 pixels
of gap. So I'm going to come back over here
and give 80 pieces of gap as well. Okay,
so in order to do it quickly, I'm going
to click it over here like this shift plus a,
okay. And then I'm going to click over here,
and I'm going to keep it on the very middle like
this. And then I'm going to right at over here,
and this actually should set to 81
ad ended. There we go, we're done.
And regarding the flex, and regarding this little
flex over here, I'm going to pause the video and
completed, you do the thing, you pause the video
and create these flakes over here, as I have
showed you how to create these flakes. So then
I'm going to see you in a couple of minutes.
So far, so good, we actually forgot to include the
layout grid. So what I'm going to do is I'm going
to click over here and then layout grid enabled by
clicking it like this, okay. And then I'm going to
click over here and then change it to columns,
okay, sorry, not rows, columns, like this. And
I'm gonna set the margin to 50 pixels over here
like this, okay. And then gutter should be 30,
like this. All right. Now we're going to snap now
now we're going to snap the content to the very
right side over here like this. And then we're
going to snap this image, this illustration to the
very left side over here like this. Okay, there we
go. Looks quite good. We're done with this section
over here. Now I'm going to show you how you can
make cards. Now I'm going to show you how you can
make cards over here like this, okay, so I'm going
to create a frame over here, F, okay, and then
select this option over here. And then I'm going
to keep it side by side over here. All right,
now look at this over here. So you do manually.
So you do all of this works manually. Okay, I'm
just gonna copy and paste it over here. I'm just
going to show you how to create these cards. Okay,
so I'm going to copy from here like
this, and all drag it like this, okay.
And I'm gonna keep this LMS moving as long
as I didn't see that orange colored skies,
okay, like this. Look at that. You see the
orange juice, it's orange colored guys over
here like this, that I'm gonna release it right
now like this. Alright, then. So I'm gonna.
Now I'm going to do the same thing for
this video elements over here like this,
okay, including the button, Alt, drag like
this. Okay, I'm going to keep it over here.
Now, select the first frame, I
mean the original design, okay,
and see the grids like this. So I'm going
to click over here like this, wait a minute,
we have 77 pixels of margin and gutter tied
to pixels. So I'm going to click over here and
click the layout grid over here like this. So I
want to change it to columns over here, okay, so
the margin is 77 pixels, so 77 into like this, and
the gutter was how much let me actually inspect it
again, a 32. Okay, click it again. Click this 132
over here. Okay, wait a minute, 32 There we go.
And we should have how many columns,
three columns. Okay, click this,
three, enter. All right now. Now what you're
going to do is you're going to click over here
and remove this columns like this and double
click over here on the cards. Look at this.
Width and Height. Look at this one. Look at
the width and height of our card number one,
okay, this 400 in width by 633 in height. So I'm
going to come back over here and I'm going to
select a rectangle, right click on my keyboard,
okay, click over here like this, which should
be fine. 400 Okay, enter, and what should be
the height let's actually inspect like this
633. Okay, so click over here like this, right
633633, enter. There we go, we have our cards,
okay, I'm going to place it over here, like this
and water. And now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to remove the color you see this color
is dark gray color. Okay, so I'm gonna snap it
over here on my layout grid, okay. And then I'm
going to remove in order to remove the color, you
click this minus sign over here, like this. And in
order to see the rectangle, you click this stroke
over here, okay, and then select it to three
pictures like this, or perhaps even four to four,
enter, there we go. And now with this border
radius, we also have border radius around our
main design, okay, so I'm going to create, so
I'm going to create a border radius over here
by clicking over here like this. Wait a minute,
there we go. It should be 15 pixels. Okay? Look,
it looks quite good. And looks like the original
one as well. And I'm going to select this, and I'm
going to create two more copies, okay, Alt, drag,
like this. Do it again, Alt and drag like this.
There we go. I'm gonna give you the
top over here like this. I'm gonna
take it, I'm gonna take it off the top as well.
And look at this. I'm going to place it at the
Center for a grid like this, okay, like this,
wait a minute, like this. There we go. Now how
to place these images, Okay, come back to assets,
okay? You see these three images over here?
Let's copy them, okay, by selecting
them one by one, by selecting them all
by selecting all of them together, right Shift,
click, click on the name, click on the name,
okay, now out copy, like this out, drag over here
like this, okay, now, right click, move to page
desktop like this, okay, and go to next up, zoom
out and see where is it? Here is our image, okay,
click over here, click over here, click
over here like this, bring it over here.
Like this. And do you remember the
steps, you're gonna click over here. And
you're gonna scroll at the very bottom over here,
and remove this vector from here, okay, delete,
click here, click on this, click on this frame
over here, and then change it to group over here,
like this now is going to remove all
our extra additional white spaces, okay,
now drag it over here like this, come over here
on the main design, control, I mean, select
this one and look at this width and height, 359
Ctrl, this one and come over here, select this,
select this little constraint button over here,
like this, and paste it over here like this.
Ctrl V, enter. There we go. We have a little icon
over here, we can place it over here like this.
And you'll see this, we have a little part
over here. Do you see this part? We didn't
have this part over here. Okay, so in order to
remove that, we're going to come over here and
Ctrl, click like this and hit the Delete keyboard,
hit the delete key on your keyboard and it is
going to get vanished like that. Look at that.
There we go. Let's copy the name from here Ctrl,
click alt drag, like this, the same
process for the music and pharmacy as well.
Like that control, click alt drag over here like
this and do the same process. The same process
for this images over here. you pause the video,
take a minute and complete the process. Okay,
I'm going to come back in a minute. All right,
now I'm done doing the process. Now what we are
going to do is we're going to center our image
and the text at the very center of our card.
How do we do this, we're going to click
both the illustration and the chemistry
like this. And I'm going to shift plus a or click
this orange layout over here like this. Okay,
now look is gonna get at the very center. And
the next thing that you're gonna do is, you're
gonna click it over here like this, and click
it over here to keep it keep it at the center
both horizontally and vertically. Okay, like
this, look at that. Okay, and click it over here
again and remove all of this gap over here, get
zero like this, enter. Now what you're gonna do
is you're gonna copy this button from here, okay,
control, control, click over here, like this, and
alt drag, okay, place it over here like this.
Do the same for all the cards as well like this.
Now let's look at the gap between our button
and our text. Okay, so I'm going to come over
here and control click and hold, press the Alt
button on your keyboard and put your mouse on
this text over here. Now look, we have 19 pixels
of gap, okay, so I'm going to come back over here,
click this one and click this one by clicking my
shift key by clicking my shift key on my keyboard
like this. Shift plus a it should be 90 Okay,
I'm going to put 19 over here. And in order to
put this button on the very center, I'm going
to click this over here and click this. There we
go. Now click both of them together like this.
Now you're going to click and then all plus h,
which means that we're going to center both of
them horizontally and vertically together. So out
plus h, all plus h, all plus v like that, look at
that we have horizontally and vertically centered
both the card and the content. Okay, like that.
And I'm going to select both of them together.
And I can either group them together
in a group, or I can also use or allow,
so I'm going to just use the group, okay, Ctrl G,
like that. It became a small group over here. Now
you duplicate the same process and fix these cars
over here. Okay, I leave this to you. Do you see
this design over here, this is the same as number
one over here and number two over here. Okay,
so you're going to do this on your own. Also, I
believe that you can make this footer over here.
So I'm not doing this. I'm just giving this
for you. Now, let me show you how I made these
cards over here. Okay, so I'm going to come
back to my assets over here. And I'm going to
come to, let's say that I want to see like just
the first one, okay, I'm going to see like this,
and alt drag over here like this, okay,
right click, move to page dekstop. Okay,
like this, it moved to my desktop, let
me zoom out, here is my asset over here,
I'm going to keep it over here. Oh, by the
way, what you're gonna do is you're gonna
move this to the right by clicking
over here, Shift, click like this.
Okay, you're going to select all of them together
like this. And you're going to move it like this.
There we go, it got moved over here, like
this. And I'm going to come over here, and I'm
going to select my F on my keyboard, okay, F and
then I'm going to create this Dexter frame like
this, look at that, and I'm gonna drag it over
here like this. There we go. And regarding this,
and regarding the navbar, what I'm going to do is
I'm going to copy it from here, okay, and then I'm
going to paste it over here, like this out, and
then drag it over here like this. There we go.
But before that, we also need to enable
the layout grid like this control,
click this over here, and then layout
grid over here and change it to
columns, columns over here. And then what is the
margin? click over here and enable this over here
like this. Look at that. We have this column, grid
over column grid over here, select this over here,
and we have three columns. And how many margins
50 pixels of margin, okay, 70 pixels of gutter.
So come back over here, like this. Select
this over here, right through over here. Okay.
So how much was it 50 and 7050 pixels margin 70
pixels gunner, come back over here, and right
50. Wait a minute, 50 over here, and 70 gutter.
There we go. Okay, now, so I'm going to select
the first image over here, good double click
over here like this, double click over here,
double click again over here. Now keep
clicking, unless you do select the image, okay,
like this look. Now I have selected the image.
Look at that. I can see the width and height over
here as well. So I'm going to copy the width over
here like this Ctrl C. Now I'm going to come back
over here. Okay, I'm going to select my frame over
here you see this white space? How to remove that,
you're gonna click over here and convert it to a
group like this. Now look, we don't have any white
space. So click on here like this, and then enable
this one, okay, constraints property and then
pays the width over here like this. Ctrl V, enter.
There we go. We have our image over here. Okay,
now how do I know how did I do this circle
over here? Pretty straightforward, okay,
you're gonna see like this circle, why Ctrl. Click
like this. Now look at this, I have a circle of
198 by 198 pixels. Okay, so I'm going to click
my zero, I'm on my key on my keyboard like this,
enter a sorry, click. Now look at this. I have
this circle over here, like this constraints
properly and right 198 like this, 198, enter.
Okay, now what you're gonna do is you're gonna
keep it over here like this, look at that. In
case if the circle is something like, in case,
if the circle looks something like this,
wait a minute, let me actually show you.
In case the cycle looks something like this, what
you're gonna do is you're gonna right click on the
circle, Send to Back like that. Okay? And I'm
gonna keep it over here unless I don't see that
orange colored guide. Okay, look at that.
It's gonna be it should be at the very
center over here. Okay? If you don't see the
guys watching, we're gonna do is you're gonna
select both of them together and hit alt H, which
means center horizontally, like that. Now, you're
going to select both of them together. And then
do you see this option over here used as a mask.
I'm going to select this. Now look at that, I have
this option over here. Again, make a circle, okay,
zero on your keyboard, click over here, and then
use this 198 like this, tap. Sorry, enter like
this. Now, there we go. Now what you're gonna do
is you're gonna remove the field from here, do you
see this? It has a field, it is green color. Do
you see this gray color over here on our circle,
you're going to remove the circle, fill, and then
select the stroke over here and select three over
here like this, enter. Now what you're going to
do is you're going to bring it over here like
this. Yes. Do you see this over here, now bring
it over here like this. Now, if you if you move
the circle, if you try to move the circle like
this, you're gonna see orange colored Guide,
which will snap now what you're gonna do is you're
gonna select your circle, okay, control, click
like this, okay? Now keep moving your circle,
unless, as long as you don't see the orange
colored, orange colored Guide, which snaps at the
very center, we're here like this, look at that.
It is actually getting snapped over here.
the very center, we're here, look at that.
Okay, now what you're gonna do is you're
gonna select both of them together like this,
and Ctrl G. Okay, now look, it got fixed. Okay,
so we're done making this profile image over here.
Now, what you're gonna do is you're going to click
it over here, like this and drag it over here.
But before that, you need to make this car.
Okay, so how to make this car. So I'm gonna
double click over here and see these properties
look with is 399. Let's consider it 400. Okay,
so 400 or 400, which is a perfect
square. So I'm going to come over here,
on my keyboard, click over here, like this. And
what I'm going to write is 400, or 400. Okay,
I'm going to click this over here and write 400.
Over here, 400, Enter. And I'm going to remove
the field from here completely. Now let's
go actually see the main image Ctrl, click
like this, and look at this, we have our stroke
property of four and this color, okay, Ctrl C,
I'm going to copy this stroke color, like that
I'm going to see and then I'm going to select our
rectangle, okay, like this. If you don't see the
rectangle, what you're gonna do is you're gonna
select like this. Now look, I can see my invisible
rectangle, like this stroke over here, and basic
color, Control V, enter, and then I'm gonna
write three over here like this. There we go.
Now regarding the book, now regarding the
shadow watts, you're going to do is you're gonna
click over here, you can just copy and paste the
shadow or what you can do is you can select this
over here like this, and then click this FX over
here, okay, and drop shadow, right then over here,
and then on the y axis as well like this, enter.
Okay, now I'm going to remove the guides from here
by clicking this. Now you see this, we have a
little odd behavior over here, you see this,
we have white colored space over here that
is unexpected. So in order to remove that,
what you're gonna do is you're gonna click it over
here like this, wait a minute, we're gonna click
this rectangle over here, I mean square over here,
and then we're going to fill it with the color.
Okay, color off white, complete, pure white, okay,
fff. In turn, now look, the problem is solved.
Then what you're gonna do is you're gonna either
write the text over here or copy the text from
here, okay, control, click out, drag like this,
okay. And then I'm going to put my image over here
like this, you will see something like this, right
click, and bring it to front like this. Okay? Now
control. Now, select both of them together, like
this, and shift plus a, and then select this
option over here, up at the middle like this,
and select both of them together, shift plus a,
and then also not see shift plus a, sorry,
click both of them together, out V and alt H,
which is center, both horizontally and vertically.
Okay, then I'm going to make it a group control
g like that. There we go, we made ourselves a
card component over here along with the profile,
picture image. Now what you're gonna do is you're
going to replicate the same thing. So pause the
video and complete the process over here and
now and I'll be back after a while. Alright,
then we're done making our teachers page now just
copy this footer from here that you made earlier.
Okay, click over here, and then paste it
over here like this. There we go. Now look,
now look at these two pages over here, the Contact
Us page and the signup page over here, both of
them looks more or less the similar. I'm going to
show you how you can make this one the Contact Us
page. And you're going to make this on the signup
form page on your own. Sounds good. Now let's get
started. Now I'm going to now I'm going to zoom
out and I'm going to select this over here by
clicking and then Shift, click Shift, click
OK. I'm gonna keep it on the right side over
here like this. Now I'm going to zoom in over
here and select a new create a new frame, okay,
F and then desktop like this. There we go. And
I'm going to resize it a bit like this way. Wait
a minute. There we go. Now I'm going to copy
this. Now I'm going to copy this from here,
wait a minute, I'm going to select both of them
together and control like this. There we go.
And look, we are in the Contact Us page,
which means that we need to change this
underline. Okay, so I'm going to
come to this RTL design over here,
and I'm going to select this. And I'm going to
drag it over here. In this contact us page, okay.
There we go. And then I'm going to drag it
to cover the cover all the area like this.
And same thing for the teacher section as
well. You see this one over here. So when
we are on the signup page, this underline
should be on the signup page as well. Okay,
sounds good. Now I'm gonna come back over here.
Now I'm gonna just copy this text from here.
out, drag it over here like this. And here to keep
it at the very center, select both of them Ctrl G,
and then alt, H. Now look, it's going to
be at the very center for frame over here.
Now how did I make this icons along with
the address, phone number, etc. Now I'm
going to come back to my assets page over here,
and you see these images over here, this icon,
I'm going to copy this from here, okay, out and
then drag over here, okay? Then select both of the
all of them together, right click, move to page.
Next up, okay, so I'm going to come back next top,
zoom out and find there is my icons over here.
Okay, then I'm gonna bring it over here like this.
And I want to select the key on my keyboard,
okay, and then I'm going to resize it like this.
Okay, I'm going to make it a small like this, and
I'm going to drag it over here. Okay, I actually
need to make it a little bit more smaller. Wait
a minute. There we go. It looks quite good. And
let's actually make it. There we go. It looks
quite good. Okay. Now regarding the address, okay,
let's inspect what is the address, font size,
okay. Ctrl Click to do that we have 30 pixels,
font size, regular Poppins. Okay, so now let's
actually duplicate the same thing key, enter, ABC,
ABC at the rate gmail.com. Okay. Now, in order
to center the icon and the text both here, I
would vertically, select both of them together
and hit alt H. Now both of them are centered.
Now Ctrl G to log the position. Okay, now
I'm going to keep it over here like this. And
we're getting this one. Select again, t enter,
okay, 123456. Okay, now look what I do, okay,
select both of them together. And alt, h There
we go. By the way, I actually changed my mind,
instead of making a group, make it a
frame, okay, so click over here like this
Ctrl, Shift G to remove the group, okay, and
hit Shift plus a shift plus a like this, and
click this over here and put it at the very
center. We're here like this. Now coming back
over here, in let's inspect this one. What is
the gap between our text and the image over here,
okay, there's inspect by clicking on here and then
alt, hold your mouse over here. 31 pixels, okay,
so come back over here, click this right 31
over here, do you want enter, there we go.
Same thing goes for same thing goes for here
as well. Select both of them, shift plus a,
and click this over here is going to be 31 over
here. 31, enter. There we go. Give it over here
for now. And let's look at this one, it should be
ABC comma D, F, okay? So D click like this, A, B,
C comma D, E, F, okay. Select both of them
together like this shift plus a, give me the
center like this. There we go. And now select all
of them together like this. So they shift plus a
and then keep it at the center over here like
this in order to move it at the very center,
hit all plus h like that, change the gap a
little bit to let's say 180 pixels like this,
and click over here and again, do alt plus h
which is center horizontally. Or you can also
use this options over here as well. Alright,
so far, so good. Now let's make this input
fields. Okay. So let's inspect this one over here,
control click, so 416 pixels by 82 pixels. Okay,
so I'm going to come back over here like this.
hit F on your keyboard, sorry, on your keyboard
to make it rectangle, okay, like this. So it was
416 416, enter. The height was I actually forgot
sorry, it was 82. Okay, so I'm going to click it
over here like this, and eight over here, enter.
Then I'm going to remove this field by selecting
this minus over here again, minus and then
stroke plus 123. Okay, enter, then increase the
corner radius to 12 pixels. Okay, there we go, it
looks quite identical to this one. Now regarding
this text, how do we input the text? Okay,
so I'm going to come over here and inspect, okay?
Ctrl, enter. So we have 20 pixels of font size.
So I'm going to come over here and
right click and write your name,
and let dot dot dot dot like this. Okay? It
should be 20. So I just turned it over here.
And now let's center it over here. So select both
of them together and alt h are not all a sorry,
Alt v like this. Okay. Now I'm going to keep it
I'm going to keep the text sorry, not this one
in the text over here like this. There we go. It
looks quite good. And I'm going to come back over
here. And do you see this? It looks, this is the
original design, do you see this color over here?
In order to replicate the same? I'm going to
come to my original design over here. Okay,
I want to control click over here. And do you see
this transparency over here it is set to 100%. I
want to set it to 50%. Okay, control 50, enter,
there we go. We've replicated the same thing.
Now what you're gonna do is you're going to
click and select both of them, then Ctrl G,
I have made a group over here, okay? out, drag
like this, okay? And write your email over here.
Email over here, like like this. Okay, there we
go. Now, how do we make this, this text over here,
the same process, Okay, I'm gonna control click
over here and see if inspect the elements, okay,
for one for Y to 10 is the dimension over here.
So let's do it. So I'm gonna click over here and
copy it, like this over here, like this. And I'm
just gonna simply drag it over here like this.
There we go. And I'm going to click over
here and Ctrl Shift G to release the
grouping. Like that. I'm going to right over
here, your message here. message here. Okay,
now I'm going to select this option over here,
do you see this option, or width? There we go.
And I'm going to keep it over here like this. Then
Ctrl G to lock our positions. Alright, looks good.
Now let's see the spacing. Okay, I'm going
to click this first element, not this one,
and then hit Alt on your keyboard, move your
mouse. So from here to here it is 50. From
here to here it is how much 46 Okay, there's
duplicate the same, okay, it should be shift
plus a, and 46 over here, okay. And from here to
there, it should be within shift plus a, okay,
and then center it over here like this. It should
be 50. Okay, right 50 over here, like this. 50,
enter. So we have nailed our gaps. Okay, now
keep it at the very center, okay, like this,
Alt H, like that, and button. And regarding the
button, you make the bottom yourself. So I'm
leaving this signup form to you, this is the same
process as this one. Okay. This Contact Us form
and this one over here, this first page over here,
I really hope that you can do it on your own.
Congratulation guys, we have successfully
completed the web design for the next version.
Now we're going to create the design for the
mobile version, the mobile design is over here
on this page over here, why don't we if you can
recall, I have created these two pages over here,
the laptop and the tablet version over here.
Along with that, I have also included the style
guides over here, I mean, the typography guides
over here, so that you can practice on your own
at your house. This is your homework. So I'm
going to come back move version over here and
then I'm gonna show you how I made this design
over here. Okay, so let's get started. Alright,
the first things first, I'm going to move
all of these elements all the way right side,
so that I can create new frames, okay, so I'm
going to select all of them together like this,
okay, like that. And then I'm going to
move it by clicking over here and then drag
dragging over here like this. Alright, there
we go. Now I'm going to zoom in here over here
like this. Now I'm going to click the F on my
keyboard like this, and then I'm going to select
this phone option over here and then I'm and then
I'm gonna click this over here, iPhone 11 Pro Max,
like this. There we go. We have our frame over
here, and then I'm going to align it like this
according to this frame. And then I'm going to
select this one rjL one, okay, like this. And
then I'm going to look at the border radius over
here. I mean corner. Yes, it is set to 40 pixels,
okay? So I'm going to take this over here, and
I'm going to say over here how much 40 like this,
okay, enter. Now let's make this navbar over here,
you see this one? Okay, so I'm gonna Ctrl click
on this logo over here and see its properties.
It is set to semi bold Poppins font family and
font sizes, 48 pixels over here, okay? So I'm
going to come back over here, okay. Click on this
hc t on my keyboard and click OK. So I'm
going to write a do sorry, a Jew dot Pio,
like this and is also and then I'm going to change
the settings to for gate over here. Like This
semi bald and then Poppins. Alright, looks good.
I'm going to keep it over here like this. There we
go. Now, how do you create this hamburger menu
icon over here? Okay, so you have two options,
you can manually create that. Or what you
can do is you can download it from somewhere,
I mean, download the icon from some website,
like freepik, and many others. Alright, today,
I'm going to show you manually how to create this
hamburger menu icon. So let's get started. Okay,
so I'm going to first of all, I'm going to
inspect this element, okay. Ctrl, click like this,
and then I'm going to see it properly. So
how much is it set? width is 30 pixels,
and the height is four pixels. All right? So
I'm going to come over here like this. And
I'm going to draw a what rectangle Okay, on my
keyboard and then drag it like this. All right,
I'm going to right over hit 30. And what was the
height, it was four, four, enter, there we go.
Now I'm going to say to which color Tell me not
black, it is this color, I'm going to come to
this Dexter option over here. And I'm going to
come to my color palette over here you see this?
This color over here. Okay, so I'm going to
click it over here and copy it like this.
Alright, so I'm going to go back to the mobile
version. And I'm going to come over here, and
I'm going to paste it over here like this on this
section, okay? Ctrl V, enter. Oh, now I'm going to
create it three times, okay, I will replicate
it three times. Okay, one. So how I did this,
okay, let me show you control that, first of all,
you're going to hit Alt on your keyboard, okay,
and then drag your mouse like this. Okay, there
we go. And then do the same thing again, like
this alternate keyboard and drag. There we go. Now
let's come to the original one over here. And what
you're going to do is you're going to Ctrl on your
keyboard and click like this, okay, now hit Alt on
your keyboard, and then move your mouse to this
portion over here, I'm in the second line, okay,
so that you can see the gap between the first and
the second line is how much five pixels, okay.
So I'm going to come over here. And what I'm
going to do is I'm gonna multi select all of
them like this, okay, and shift plus a, now send
rate like this. And then I'm gonna click it over
here and you see this gap properly. I'm gonna say
two, five, enter, there we go. All set. Now what
you're gonna do is you're gonna center both the
logo and the icon, horizontally, okay? select both
of them together, like this, and shift plus a. Now
look, the icon jumped at the very top. Let's fix
that by clicking this over here and keep it at the
very center horizontally like this. There we go.
Now let's come to the origin document
over here and click this. Okay,
now let's see its layout. Great. Okay, so I'm
gonna click this icon over here like this. And
then I want to inspect this one, okay? It has
how many columns, one column margin is 20 pixels.
Now, let's recreate the same Okay, so I'm going
to click over here like this, and click this.
Okay. Layout grid. There we go. And I'm going to
change it to what columns and then one over here
and how much is the margin? 20 margin. Okay, there
we go. Now, what you're gonna do is you're gonna,
I mean, we're gonna lie it over here, okay? I
mean, the logo and the hamburger icon, okay, so
we need to increase the gap so that we can
stretch it, I will stretch the icon to the VA,
right on my, on our layout grid. Okay,
like this. We're gonna. Okay, there we go.
Looks good. Now, I'm gonna
come back to the Wait a minute.
Yeah, it looks good. Now I'm gonna come back
over here, click this, okay. And now look,
what I do. I'm going to select the Alt
on my keyboard after clicking this nav
bar over here, and then all on my keyboard. And
I'm going to put my mouse on this screen over
here so that I can see the gap between the screen
and my content. Okay? It is 19 pixel over here,
and 10 pixel at the top. If I come over here is
going to be the same, I guess no strange. Okay.
So I'm going to keep 19 over here. Okay, so how
do I do that? countries that, let's see if it is
okay or not. Okay, so I'm going to click this one,
almost on my keyboard and then put my mouse over
here, this 20 over here. And over here it is how
much 21. So there is one pixel difference, okay?
Not big difference. So let's actually increase
one pixel over here, click this one, and then
come over here and just increase one. How do you
do this, click the up arrow sign on your keyboard,
okay, like this. And then the problem is fixed.
Now let's inspect, okay, so click this over here,
altering your keyboard, put your mouse over
here, so it is 20 over here and on this side,
out, and then look at this 20 over here
as well, but at the top it is how much
nine. So move it a little bit, just what
one pixel Okay, so click this and then
down arrow on your keyboard, down like this. Now
let's inspect alternative keyboard. Keep it over
here. We're going to stand 2020 this symetrical
Alright, looks good. Now. Regarding the image,
how do we work with this same thing, come
to assets over here and look at this one,
okay? Click on here, Alt on your keyboard,
drag over here like this, okay? Right click,
move to page, what mobile. Alright, so zoom
out a little bit so that you can see where
our asset got transferred, okay, so it is
transferred over here, bring it over here, like
this drill is the same, okay, you're gonna double
click over here, or what you can do is you can
just click on here or not here, sorry, over here,
and you're going to select, I mean, you see all
of this vector gets selected, okay, just select
the very last one, okay, there's one, and Delete
on your keyboard. Like this, it got deleted, and
look at this white space. If I click this name
over here, you see this unnecessary white space.
In order to remove them. Click this frame over
here as a group. There we go. All our unnecessary
work split whitespaces went away. So I'm going to
keep it over here. Look, it's very big. Okay, so
we need to resize it rescale. Either you can hit
K, either you can hit k on your keyboard, or just
hit shift on your keyboard and just drag it over
here like this. Alright, like this. Let's do it
manually instead of copying the properties from
here. Okay, let's manually shift, hold shift
on your keyboard and drag like this. Again,
it's gonna resize proportionately legs. Okay,
now, you're gonna follow the orange right? Now
you're going to follow the orange guides over
here, you see this orange guides resuming. You
can see the orange colored guides, okay, you see
these guides, you see that? It's snapping. Okay,
so I'm going to stretch it till my layout grid
over here. Okay, there we go. Boom. Notice inspect
the gap between our nav item, I mean, nav bar and
our image, okay, on the original document, click
this alternate keyboard and put it over here.
47. So click this alternate keyboard over here.
So 36 point 71. So what was this? 47? Okay, so
I went to, sorry, which is over here, let's see.
This must get click over here and all to put it
over here is 58. Okay, it should be 47. So shift
plus up. Let's see how much is that we have moved
10 pixel up. So out on your keyboard, this 48 so
it was 47. So click it, click again and put it in,
press up arrow sign one thing like this. Now look,
it's equal measurement. Alright. And regarding
this flakes over here, you see this little flakes.
Okay? You want to put them on your own. Okay, so
I'm going to leave it as it is, because I showed
you how to recreate this doodles over here, this
flakes over here, okay, what you're gonna do is
you're gonna come to assets over here, okay? And
then you're gonna use this assets over here, okay?
All right, let's come back to the mobile over
here. Let's duplicate this text over here and
create the button. All right, now click
this altar on your keyboard and drag over
here like this. Okay. By the way, I also given
this chart over here, the typographic guide,
like what should be the size, font size of
the logo, and the large text, small text, size
button, etc. so that you can make all
elements with accurate calculations. Okay?
So zoom out and come over here. Alright, so what
we are going to do is we're going to copy this
over here as well. Okay? Like this, click
over here, Alt, drag like this. All right,
there we go. Now let's see how to create this
button over here. Okay, the same thing, okay,
what you're gonna do is you're gonna hit t on your
keyboard, okay, then, click like this. Now you're
gonna write log in like this. Okay, now come over
here and inspect the original document, click,
hit Ctrl. And then take a look, we have font size
of 24, remoto. Both. All right, so come over here,
right 24 Robo Joe, and then it should be how much
Bose There we go. And we're gonna change the color
to white because it is because the original one
is white in color. All right, like this F F F
three times, all right, six times, Okay, it looks
invisible. Now what you're gonna do is you're
gonna hit Shift plus a on your keyboard and make
all the way up like the shift plus eight. Okay?
In case you can't find your invisible button over
here, do this. Okay, if you select like this, then
you can select your button. All right. Now come
at the bottom over here and hit fill, and fill it
with a color black 000, enter. There we go. Now
we can see our button. Okay, so come over here,
click. I'm in control, click, look at the height.
It is 55.41. Let's consider it 55 and the width
is 374 which is I will which stretches from
the very left to the very right to all layers.
Great. So what is the border? Yes. 9.49. Okay,
so click over here, right the border. Yeah,
I'm in corner. Yes. 9.49. All right, there we go.
Now the height is how much 55. Look at this, the
height and the width is locked in order, unlock
it, just come over here and drag it a little bit
over here, like this resize a little bit over
here, the height gets unlocked. And do the same
over here a little bit over here, the width gets
unlocked as well. All right, now in order to,
if you notice carefully that you can see that
the text is not at the very center have a button,
how to do it, just click over here, center like
this both horizontally and vertically. Okay,
now the height of the button should be 55,
enter, and the width, instead of doing it
manually, instead of doing it over here, directly,
just put it over here like this, and then drag
like this, okay? extend till the end over here
like this. Okay, there we go. Now, copy the button
over here like this. All right, now control,
click, double click over here and then sign up.
There we go. And then what you're gonna
do is you're gonna click both of them,
then hit Shift plus a, and now sending the
button both horizontally and vertically together
like this. Alright, now let's inspect the gap
between our first and the second button. Okay,
click, sorry, control, click, control, click on
the original button, and then out, hold your mouse
over here how much it is 17 pixels of gap, okay,
so come over here. And click this and it should be
1717. There we go. All right, now looks good. Now
I'm gonna remove the layout grid from here like
this. Okay, along with that, remove the layout
grid of the original document as well look at
that it looks symmetrical, identical, except the
flex over here, okay, except this flex over here,
because I have kept this for you, so that you can
do it on your own. Alright, now look at the second
frame over here, this is the same as the first
one, okay, so what you have to do is you're gonna
click f4 on your keyboard, then phone camera phone
option, and then click iPhone 11 Pro max like
this, and you're going to get this frame over here
like this, resize it, you don't have to resize it
because it's perfect measurement. And then what
you're going to do is you're going to come to this
over here, okay, click over here, Alt, drag
like this, and then paste over here like this.
There we go. And you're getting this one,
inspect the corner yet is 40 pixels. So
40 pixel over here as well for zero, enter, and
we're getting layer grid, click over here, okay,
sorry, two columns. 20 off gap between the
pixel gap, column count should be one. Okay,
and there we go. And now what you're gonna do
is you're gonna center it over here like this,
at the very center vertically, or what you can
do is, you can just keep it over here, like this,
and just click it and alt H, which means center
horizon view like this, or what do you have the,
or you also have this option over here, you see
this, we have the Align Horizontal Centers, okay,
I'm going to keep it over here like this, click it
over here, like this, look at that it got centered
horizontally. All right, so I'm gonna keep it
over here like this. aggroing. Good, according
to our design over here. All right, now I'm
going to leave this entire design on your hands
because I truly believe that you can do it on
your own because this one is similar to this
one over here, the first frame over here, okay,
so I'm not doing this, you're gonna do it, okay,
including this little doodles over here. Okay,
so you're gonna do this on your own as well.
Now we're gonna move on to the next section over
here, you see this? We're gonna make cards over
here on our offered courses section. Okay,
so how do we do this? Okay, so first of all,
create a frame over here F on your keyboard,
okay, and then select this iPhone 11 Pro Max,
okay, so I need over here like this. I mean,
with the original document at the top like this,
look at that. We have our orange color guides over
here. Okay, now click on this, select the corner
radius, corner radius to 40 over here, and there
we go. And now you can stretch it till over here,
unless as long as it doesn't snap over here at the
bottom, you can see the orange colored guides. If
I zoom in a little bit over here, you can see
the orange colored guides, Okay, there we go.
I mean, it's gonna snap, okay, you can feel it,
that it aligned together. Now what you're gonna
do is you right click our frame over here
by selecting this name over here and then
layout grid, right click on this and select
columns, just one column, enter. All right,
now click on the original document over here and
select this. Not this. Sorry, this one. Okay,
let's, let's inspect how much margin do we have?
We have 20 pixels of margin. Okay, so this one,
on our practice case, it should be 20 pixels of
margin as well. So click OK. So So click over here
and select training. Okay, enter. There we go. Now
regarding this nav bar, you know the drill, right?
Just copy it from here, like this out and then
drag over here like this. There we go. And in
order to center this nav bar horizontally, what
you're gonna do you remember, Alt H, or select any
one, or select this option over here. Okay? All
right, looks good. Keep it over here at the top.
Okay, now in order to complete these designs
very quickly, what you're going to do is you're
going to come to this Dexter option over here,
okay? And this is our offered courses. This is
the original one. And this is the practice case
over here. Okay, so I'm going to click over here
and and then select Alt on my keyboard and drag
over here like this. All right, look at that. I
have successfully copied it. And now right click,
move to page what mobile Alright, come to mobile,
zoom out to find the frame. That is it, we have
our there is it, we have our frame over here. drag
it over here like this, again, this corner. And
now what you're gonna do is you're gonna see like
this text over here, along with the underline,
okay? Copy, throw out, drag like this. All right,
there we go. And now what you're gonna do is
you're gonna shift and then resize like this.
Or what you can do, you can just even hit k
on your keyboard and drag like this. Alright?
Now look at this, it is getting small
proportionality. Okay, now I'm going to keep
it over here, you can take the help of the orange
color guys like this, okay? Or what you can do is
you can just keep it over here as it is and
click it, Alt H or select this option, okay?
align content horizontally. There we go. And let's
inspect the gap between this one and the left
nav bar, like this out and put your mouse over
here. 38 pixels, okay? click over here, alternate
keyboard, put it over here, this 59. Okay, so
what you have to do is you have to just give it
over here, and let's inspect right now, alternate
keyboard, select 40. Okay, so I'm going to click
here, and then press the up arrow two times one,
two. Now it's 38. accurate. All right, looks good.
If we're going to if we're going to recall,
we made this card on the desktop version,
okay? Although that that now in order to make
the design for the mobile version, very quickly,
we're going to take the help of oral layout. So
what we're gonna do is, we're gonna select all
our cards together like this, okay? And then shift
plus a like this. Do you see this option over here
is this called the oral l? Do you see this
little button over here? Oh, by the way,
you're going to click this over here, and
then center both horizontally and vertically,
like this. And now you'll see this little
button over here, this is activated, which is,
which is align content horizontally. Now we're
going to select align content vertically like
this, you see this button over here, click
this Now look, it made us content for our
mobile version, okay, so I'm going to drag from
here to here like this, okay. And then I'm gonna,
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna keep it I will
align without layout grid over here, like this,
right now when I select key on my keyboard,
or hold, shift, and then resize your
cards like this, as long as it doesn't snap to
our layout. Great on the right, okay, like this.
There we go. It looks quite good, I guess,
click over here and put it at the top like this.
There we go. Okay, now it looks quite big compared
to our design over here. So in order to adjust
the settings, what we're going to do is we're
going to click over here, double click Okay,
and then double click again, double click
again, as long as we don't see this blue colored
lines, our lower image, okay, look at the size of
the image. Okay, you see this, just copy the width
Ctrl C. And now come over here, double click,
double click, double click as long as you don't
see the blue colored lines around our image, okay.
So I have selected this one, select this option,
okay, constraints properly, then paste the
width over here. Ctrl V, enter. There we go.
Now let's change the text. What is the font size
of this text? Okay. Ctrl. Click. Now look at this,
it is 50.7 just consider it 50 pixels, okay,
Ctrl, click, select 255 zero, enter. There we go.
And yeah, select this option over here as well
or a width. So what it will do, let me show
you the control set. What it will do you see this
extra gap over here is going to remove that extra
extra gap so that we can do our measurements
accordingly. I mean, correctly. Okay,
so click this over here now. Now you can see
that the extra gap got removed. Okay, like that.
There we go. And we're getting the button lis
instructed what what is the font size model?
Okay. Ctrl click like this. 24 pixels. Okay.
Ctrl click. So it took You fall over here,
Enter. And then look at this, we have so many gaps
over here. Okay, in order to remove those gaps,
just click this over here or
Oh, wait like this. There we go.
Alright, so far, so good. Now look at this,
we have our content on the very left side,
so we need to center it both horizontally and
vertically. And now let's look at our original
category here. Okay, so double click over
here and look at this height over here. Okay,
so I'm going to copy the height of a Ctrl C,
and then come to our practice case over here,
okay, double click over here and then paste
it over here like this, okay? Ctrl V, enter.
Alright, now, so far, so good. Now we need
to center our content both horizontally and
vertically inside our card over here. Okay, so how
do we do this, first of all, we're gonna on frame
or frame, okay, like this, I'm going to click
over here, and then click this over here, okay,
from frame, we're going to select it to group like
this, okay, and then Ctrl Shift G to remove that
group like this. Now, it doesn't have any oral
layout over here, it is just a single plane card,
I look at this over here, it is also behaving
like a group. So Ctrl, Shift G, remove that
group as well. Alright, now the next thing
that you're going to do is click this content
over here and this button over here as well.
Okay, both of them and then shift plus eight,
to put it inside a frame, okay, and then select
it to zero, like this, and let's enter. All right,
zero over here as well, there we go. It is
removing the extra whitespace from our content,
okay. And now what you're going to
do is you're gonna select both the
card and our content like this, okay? And
then shift plus a, okay, shift a, and then
centric, both horizontal and vertical. Okay,
you're gonna select this button over here,
like this, and then select this button over here,
or what you can do is you can just select alt, H,
and alt v on your keyboard like this look, or
v h like this. There we go. Now look at this.
We have so many gaps over here, but we have
a minimum gap over here. Okay, so how do we
remove those gaps? Okay, so let's inspect this
button over here, okay? Ctrl, click like this,
look at this properties, okay? Look at the
height, it is 55 pixels, okay, so I'm going to
come back over here and control click like this,
and set the height to how much it is set to 62. So
and it is also locked. So what you're going to
do is you're going to select v on your keyboard
and drag it a little bit up, okay. And now set
it to 55 pixels. Great. 55, enter, there we go.
Now, this button is not at the very center,
I mean, this text is not at the very center,
what you're going to do is you're going to click
this over here, okay. And let's send it over here
like this. There we go, boom. But still, you
have so many gaps in our content, I get it. So
let's inspect. Okay, so click over here. And
look at this, we have 7.66 pixels of gap. Okay,
so let's, let's see, to see, enter, there we
go. Now select both of them together again,
and alt v alt h to sender both of them both
horizontally and vertically. There we go.
Our bottom looks exactly the carbon copy of the
original one over here. Now, I'm going to leave
the rest of these cards, you see this card
over here, and this card over here as well.
I am leaving this to you fix them. Along with
that this design over here you see this design,
this is similar to our design, I mean frame number
one, this one and frame number two over here
as well. So do it on your own. And yeah, you're
gonna do is footer over here as well on your own.
Now we're gonna make the teachers page. Okay,
this one. All right, so zoom out a little bit
and delete this one from here, delete. All right,
and then we're going to move it to the right side.
Select properly like this. Alright, so
right so over here like this. There we go.
And now come to the next version
over here and you see this
page over here, the original document this
one, so I'm going to copy it from here, okay,
the original design, okay, click on the name over
here, Dexter for all on your keyboard and drag it
over here like this. Alright, now right click,
move to page which one mobile like this, okay,
now come to the mobile version, zoom up, find it.
Where is it here Is it okay? So I'm going to keep
it over here at the top, and I'm going to move
it. Both of them live in all these design building
designs over here on the very right over here.
Okay, let's zoom in over here. Click F on your
keyboard, select the iPhone 11 Pro max like this,
okay, drag it over here like this. And said the
border radius, I mean corner yes to 40 over here
like this, enter. Now select this layout grid, say
two columns over here and then count will be one
enter. So the margin 20 pixels over here, enter.
All right now just just replicate the nav bar by
Alt on your keyboard. drag it over here like this.
All right. Then release it like this and then alt
h to center heart, the center horizontally like
this. Okay, there we go. So far, so good. Now look
at this desktop design over here, okay? So out,
drag like this, okay, keep it over here, then
and then hit k on your keyboard, okay? Okay,
and then drag it like this, as long as it
doesn't get shrunk like this a bit like this one,
the original design. Let's make it, let's make
it a little bit smaller like this, and then
click on here, select this, or Alt h on your
keyboard. There we go. Keep it a little bit up
like this. Alright, looks good. And now select
your frame over here like this, and then
hit v on your keyboard, okay, V, and then
drag it to the very end over here like this.
There we go. So far, so good. Now we're
going to replicate the cards over here. Okay,
so how many cards? Do we have?
123? Sorry, 12345, the five cards?
Not six cards as the original design on that on
the text version. Okay, so. So do you recall that
how we made these cards over here? Okay. So what
will we use over here, the same as this one over
here, you see this design over here, we made this,
the same as this, we're gonna use the auto layout.
How do I do this, like this? Look at look, follow
me. Okay, I'm gonna select all my cars over here,
like this shift plus a, or right click and add
auto layout like this. Look at this little button
over here. Okay? It is horizontal, say to vertical
like this look, it became designed for our mobile
version, you see this? Okay, I'm going to
keep it over here like this. There we go.
Alright, and then I'm going to resize it by
hitting key on my keyboard and resizing like this.
As long as you see this one, as long as
this one, this line doesn't align with our
layout grid. Okay, like this. There we go. Oh.
And I'm gonna keep it over here like this. And
we're getting this cards over here. Same thing for
the same thing, obviously, all of them together,
and then shift plus a, and then click this over
here like this. All right, now keep it over here,
like this, and then resize it like this. Okay,
key on your keyboard, and then resize like this.
Actually, it is very big. So I'm going to keep
it over here like this. Now, what you're gonna
do is do remember how I resize this first frame
over here. Okay, on our offered courses section,
this one, do you remember how I resize this
card according to the original design, you're
gonna do the same thing over here. Okay, you're
gonna first or resize this card, and then this
two, and then you're going to resize these two
cards over here, and whether we don't need the
last one, okay, so like, we can easily I will, we
can delete this one, okay, like this still it, we
have two cards over here. Oh, by the way,
we can also place it over here like this,
there we go. Now, what you're gonna do is you're
gonna resize these cards, according to the
original file over here, I mean, the original
designer, I showed you how to do it right over
here, I showed you how to resize it according
to the original design. So do it on your own,
do this section on your own, because I truly
believe that you can do it. And regarding this
footer over here, you don't have to recreate it
again, because it is a component. I mean, this is
the original component over here, wait a minute,
this is the original component over here. And
this one, wait a second, this one is an instance
of the original document. Okay, so this is just
an instance. Okay, just copy it from here all
and then drag over here like this. There we go.
And if in case if we want to change something over
here, just changed the original document, okay,
just changed over here and everything, I will all
the children will get changed according to the
parent component. Okay. All right. Now let's look
how to make this contact us for Okay, there's one
over here. So we're going to create I mean, we're
gonna move this to the very right side like this,
select all of them together, and then drag to the
right side like this. There we go. And then come
over here and hit F on your keyboard F, you're
gonna click F on your keyboard and then select
this iPhone 11 Pro max like this, give it over
here. And what was the corner DSC room, we're
for the Texas So hey, 40 over here, okay. 40,
enter that oralia I mean layout grid over here,
say two columns over here, like this columns. And
let's set one, enter, and over here, right in the
basis of margin, there we go. Just copy the
nav bar from here because we made it once. All
right, and then what you're gonna write
is, what you're going to click is this one,
Align Horizontal Centers. There we go. Boom,
keep it up at the top like this. There we go.
Or you can just use your mouse and move it
like this. There we go. To beat over here,
and just copy this text from here. Click and then
drag like this. Alright, and in order Take it,
I mean, in order to keep it at the center of H on
your keyboard, Alt H, move it a little bit up like
this. And if you want accurate measurements, just
select this and also on your keyboard and drag,
keep your mouse over here, this 15 pixels, okay?
So I'm gonna keep, I'm going to click over here,
keep my mouse over here, like this is 30 pixels.
Okay, so let's move it a little bit up. So how to
do it, click over here and then hold shift
on your keyboard and press up like this
one, too. Okay, now let's inspect, click
over here, alternate keyboard, look,
it is 10 pixels of gap. So click over here
12345, I pressed five times the arrow down
button over like on my keyboard, like that.
Look at that is now accurate measurements.
All right, now copy this line from here as well
out, drag over here like this, okay. Then alt
h to center horizontal. That gives you the we're
here at the bottom of the get in touch text. All
right, now how to recreate them. Remember where
our assets it is over here on this assets page.
All right, not this one. This one over here. Wait
a second, this one. Okay. So I'm going to select
all of them together like this, and then out
drag like this. Then select all of them again,
right click move to page where Come on, tell me
it's mobile. So come to mobile over here, zoom
out to see where is it here Is it okay? I'm going
to select all of them together like this and then
select k on my keyboard and drag or select shift
on my keyboard, okay, and then drag like this. And
that is going to get resized like that. Okay, I
want to bring it over here like this, within that.
So it's quite big compared to this one.
You can, you can also inspect the icon
size like this control click like this,
you can see that it is with 50 pixels.
And the height is 38.09 pixels, okay? So you can
do that as well as what I'm going to just use my
Scale tool, okay, so I'm gonna select all of them
together and the hit key on my keyboard, and then
scale it down like this. There we go. All right,
now now what we're going to do is we're gonna
select this phone over here like this, okay, I
will, we're gonna make it horizontal like this.
Okay, now, let's copy the text from here,
okay, out, drag like this. Double click
out, drag like this, okay, or just click over
here, I'm in control, click over here and all,
no sorry, out, drag over here like this. Or
what you can do is just control click over here,
like this, and then alt, drag like this.
Alright, now what you're gonna do is look
at this very carefully. I'm going to select
both of them together and take the help of home
auto layout. Okay, the boss is over here, kick it
over here, like this, the plus thing. All right,
now keep it at the very center over here,
both the text and the icon like this. There
we go. Now let's keep a gap of 30 pixels,
okay? between our icon and the text. Okay,
the same thing for for here, shift a, click over
here and center it over here like this. All right.
Now, how much was the gap 30 pixels, okay, see,
like this curly, enter, go. The same over here,
shift a, how much 30, enter, see like this, keep
it at the very center. We're here. Okay? Now, so
far, so good. It looks like this one. Okay. Now,
now if you notice carefully, then you can see that
this text are not aligned to a single line. Okay,
so let me bring my ruler over here like this, like
clicking over here. And then rulers over here like
this. So I got my, so I got my ruler over here
that I'm going to click over here and then keep my
ruler over here like this. So I'm going to keep it
over here, okay, to this line. Now, if I zoom in,
then you can see that the text is over here, okay,
according to a ruler, and what this text does it
align with a ruler over here at the same time,
this text doesn't align with the ruler over
here. That's because the width of this icon
width of this icon and the width of this icon is
not the thing. So in this case, what you're gonna
do is you're gonna just remove that oralia How
to remove the auto layout, okay, click over here,
and select this group. And then what you're gonna
do is you're gonna click this and then Ctrl,
Shift g on your keyboard, remove that group. Now,
both of them behave like individual elements.
All right, same thing over here, remove
the frame to group and then Ctrl Shift key
to remove that group. Come over here. Select
this frame to group Okay, Ctrl Shift G, remove
that group. There we go. Now what you're gonna do
is select all the text over here like this, okay,
and then use auto layout shift plus a like this.
Now, our texts are at the very center here,
according to our what according to this ruler
over here, you see this ruler and you see this
continent we're here. Now if want to even
also use this one and keep it over here,
okay? On the left side of the horizontal line like
this. All right. Now regarding this icons over
here, you can do the same, you can just use auto
layout as well, by clicking all of them together,
I mean selecting all of them together and then
shift plus K. And then we need to keep it at
the center both horizontally and vertically. So
click over here and look like this. Alright, then,
so far, so good. Okay, now we're going to select
all of them together like this. Okay, and then
Ctrl G on your keyboard to lock the position. All
right, there we go. Look at that. It looks very
nice. Now click this original document over here
like this. Alright, and then alternate keyboard,
put your mouse over here like this, how much
is the gap between our address and this text?
46. There's duplicate the same as well. Click
over here and then keep it over here like this.
And the alternative would give it over here, how
much how much is this? 53 so you have to go How
much? Nine more steps? Okay, so he nine times the
up arrow sign, okay. 123456789. Now let's inspect
Okay, click on here, Alt n and then put your mouse
over here. 44. Wait a minute, it was how much?
Sorry. 46 Oh, sorry, I moved to pixel up. So I'm
gonna go to two pixels down. So click two times
the down arrow. Okay, one, two. Now it's gonna be
calamy exact measurement. Okay, so click on here
out and put it over here like this. 46. There we
go. Now let's create this form over here. Okay, so
let's inspect the first one. Okay, click Control,
click over here like this, how much is the height
63.9. Let's consider 64. Okay, so come over here.
And if you want to remove the ruler, what you're
gonna do is you're going to click over here, and
then select this rulers and the rule, go away,
like that. Now hit r on your keyboard and drag it
like this, how much was the height? 65? Right. 64.
All right, so I'm going to click over here and
write 64, Enter. And I'm going to keep it over
here like this. And I'm going to drag it until I
didn't cover the entire width of one layout. Great
like that. Now what is the border radius corner?
Yes, is 9.36. So of the RTL design, so I'm going
to click over here and write line boy 9.36 over,
hit enter, there we go. And then at some stroke,
like this, how much three, enter? Not sure sorry,
let's consider it to enter, there we go. Now,
you can see that this form at the top, and over
here are the similar, I mean, similar identical.
So what you're gonna do is you're gonna alter your
keyboard and drag over here like this, alright.
And we're getting this one, the same over here as
well drag it over here, like this, and then drag
like this, there we go, boom. And listen, let's
remove our oral layout and the layout grid from
here by selecting this or you can also remove it
permanently. But don't do that. Okay, just select
this one. And it's going to get removed, I mean,
the oral layout, so comment and whatnot over here.
You see this forms over here, select this and
remove the field. And it's gonna get white just
like our original document over here. Okay, the
same for this one. And do the same for this one as
well. Now I'm leaving the rest of the work to you.
What you're gonna do is you're going to place this
text you see this text over here, this text is
text, this text and the button on our practice
case over here. Okay? I believe that you can do
it. All right, all right. Now do you remember our
last frame over here? This is the same as this
one. Wait a minute, this one this frame that
contact us frame and this one, okay? The first
frame over here, okay? The process is the same.
You have to do it on your own. I'm leaving this
I'm leaving this to you. Alright guys, personally,
I think that this video became extremely long.
So what kind of content do you want? Do you
want very big in depth tutorial videos are short
videos, let me know in the comments down below.
So ladies and gentlemen, we're done with our
tutorial. If you liked the video, give a like,
share with a friend and feel free to subscribe.
Till then I'll see you in the next video. Bye bye